welcome to an exciting journey into the
world of full staff development with
next Cs typescript and AWS
this course was expertly designed by
Brian Huff who is a seasoned software
engineer and passionate teacher he takes
you from building a front-end with nexjs
and typescript to creating a robust
backend with AWS amplify and finally
deploying your app on AWS we'll be using
zincot's API for fetching quotes and
Diving deep into State Management hooks
debugging nosql database modeling and
much more you will Master the art of
building and deploying full stack
applications on AWS
how's it going everyone hello friends
hello world and hello free code Camp my
name is Brian huff and I'm really
excited to be creating this video
showing you how you can build with nexjs
typescript and AWS to generate images
completely serverlessly in the cloud and
I created this project as a weekend you
know really just see if I could build it
because you know I've used canva I've
used Photoshop I've used a lot of
different you know applications to make
images and I was thinking could I make
these images using technology and
programming and it turns out that you
can so I'm really excited to show this
application to you and show you exactly
how we built it and we're going to be
doing quite a lot we're going to be
configuring a nexjs with typescript
project we're then going to be
configuring our own appsync graphql API
in AWS we're then going to be using in
Lambda function to be configuring some
server code that's serverlessly deployed
to the cloud and then we're also going
to be updating a database with dynamodb
and then we're also going to be showing
how to connect the front end to the back
end and then deploy our application Live
using amplify hosting to then access our
application from any device online so if
you're excited to see this build then
you are in the right spot and to give a
little bit of context about who I am I
have been building on the cloud for the
past few years during the pandemic was
when I actually got really exposed to
AWS and what it can do because I was
building open source technology related
to cloud and cloud computing and this
was for symptom tracking and that was
really what gave me my start in cloud
and then that really mushroomed into a
lot of different opportunities that I
saw because instead of you needing to
create your own infrastructure you could
just use serverless Technologies and
then scale a lot of the business use
cases that that you might want so that
was really where I started building on
the cloud and then I started creating
content around that on YouTube and on
Instagram and then that turned into what
I created as a YouTube channel and as a
brand and as a Dev shop called the tech
stack Playbook so this has really been
an exploration for me of how can I build
technology how can I solve problems and
how can I build cool things and that's
what I see as programming today and as
an AWS Community Builder on the data
team I become really passionate about
building these types of serverless
infrastructures and data models and ways
to construct technology because it is
very empowering when you can learn how
to build
what you think about so take an idea and
then turn that you know into life bring
that to users bring that to a company
bring that to an organization that's
where I see programming becoming really
powerful so I hope that this tutorial is
really helpful and empowering for you to
see how you can turn your ideas into
code and then into a real application
that you can use on any device
so what we're creating is an
inspirational quote generator and the
way this is going to work is that when
we press a button it's going to be
calling a function in the cloud it's
going to generate this image for us and
then we're going to get a string of this
image so it's not an actual file it's
just the string that creates a file and
then we'd be able to use that in our
application so we could either save that
image copy that image open it in a new
tab or we could also download it to our
computer and I do think that's something
that is really cool about this type of
project is that we're actually going to
be able to show how this can generate
images
in a desktop application which you see
but also if we wanted to get this on a
mobile application this is what it'll
look like so when we press it here and
we press make a quote it's going to spin
and then now we have this image so now
if we click on that the image is
actually showing up on our phone and if
we want to press this again we can make
a new quote
and then we get another image there so I
think this is a really great project for
anyone that wants to learn how to create
Progressive web applications and also
show how to have one back end that can
service many different types of front
ends whether you have a mobile
application or you have a desktop
application so the way that this is
going to work at a very Baseline level
is that when we have this quote so we
made a call from the user so the user
is going to generate
a request
that's going to Ping
appsync
which is our API using graphql
that's then going to connect to an AWS
Lambda
function and then that's going to
generate
a base
64 encoded string so then this is
actually a series of digits a series of
code that actually is an image and we
actually are able to download this we're
able to copy it we're able to use it but
it's not actually saved as a file until
it reaches the application so that's
where we're able to take all of this in
the cloud and then make it run get a
response and then download this image
right from our application in our
browser I'm really excited to show you
this project and especially learning how
to build this type of serverless
infrastructure where you don't have to
provision the server yourself and
there's a lot of these managed services
to help you build with scaling so as
users are using your application as
these functions are getting called this
will actually scale with your use case
and you only pay for what you use so you
never have to worry about provisioning a
server and putting up you know money you
know up front this will be pay as you go
and there's also really generous free
tiers so that you never have to worry
about lots of expensive upfront costs
it's very accessible and scalable to
build your use case and build a fun app
which is what we're going to do today so
if you're excited about that let's get
ready to build
all right so first things first we are
going to set up a code repository for
our project so if you don't already have
an account you can go to github.com and
set up a free account it's super easy to
set up your account and then what you'll
be able to do is start allowing access
to your projects with Git so that you'll
be able to have Version Control so or
Source control for your project and what
this is going to allow us to do is think
about it like Google Docs but for your
code so you'll be able to go back in
between different branches maybe you
wanted to review code that you wrote
previously maybe you need to revert a
change that you pushed into production
well thanks to git and GitHub you'll be
able to then go back to that previous
commit and then make that the default
Branch or the default code for your
project so uh you can get to create a
new repository a couple different ways
in the drop down in your profile in the
top right you can go to repositories and
then there'll be a green button where
you can then press you know create new
repository or you can press this handy
plus button up here and then create a
new repository so we are going to name
our repository inspirational quote
generator
like so and then we'll give it a nice
description so we'll say this is our
inspirational
quotes generator project
to learn how we can run Scripts
in AWS with next JS okay great so then
we can choose between public or private
I'm going to choose private and then
once we create our Repository
we'll then see that we have now a way to
access this code repository with Git so
now that we've done this the next step
is to set up our project with GitHub
desktop so GitHub desktop is a client
that you can download also from
Microsoft to the same company that owns
GitHub and you'll be able to have this
GUI or this graphical user interface
that will let us manage our project
with this web client on our computer to
do that super easily we're going to
press this button that says setup in
desktop
we'll then open GitHub desk up here this
is going to prompt this window to open
up there actually I'll do this one more
time
so we'll do that there and then we'll be
able to choose where we want our project
to be located so I'm going to go to
my tech SEC Playbook folder
I will drop it in there
and then as soon as I press clone
it's then going to
establish a link between this folder on
my computer and then the code repository
in GitHub so now if we wanted to open in
Visual Studio code
will then be able to and you'll just say
yes I trust the authors because I trust
myself
and then um we'll be able to now get our
project this folder all set up in GitHub
desktop in one click which is awesome so
now what we want to do is we want to
start building our next JS project to
start coding all right so as you can see
on my screen I have the next JS docs up
this is the documents that are the
documentation that's maintained by the
company for cell and they maintain the
next JS project so what we are going to
be doing is we are going to scroll down
in the docs to where it says create next
app and this is the one line of code
that we need to install our framework
for working with nexjs and adding
typescript as well so something that we
can do is just right click and copy and
then in the left part of our screen and
visual studio code I'm going to control
B just to get rid of that sidebar and
I'm going to control and then tilde and
then that's how we're going to open up
our terminal so you can just do control
C just to clear that out or I can just
expand this make it a little bit easier
to see
so I'm going to open this up a little
bit so when we open up a terminal window
this is the same as opening up a
terminal window on your screen or if
you're on a Mac or this might be
Powershell if you're you know not on a
Mac but I'm on a Mac so this is what I
would be using but you can run a
basically a Powershell or a terminal
window inside of Visual Studio code
which is a great feature of the IDE so
as soon as we write this in we're going
to press enter and it's going to walk us
through a series of commands to help us
bootstrap our project so do we want to
install yes
and then what's our product name we're
going to say inspo
quote generator
but we actually it doesn't really matter
because we're going to get rid of this
folder anyway but we'll just give it
something now would you like to use
eslint we're going to say yes would you
like to use the source directory we're
just going to do the default no and we'd
like to use experimental app director
but say no and we're Alias uh we'll just
do enter and now it's going to start
generating all of the different
dependencies and Integrations for our
project and I think this is kind of like
the the fun part of coding just seeing
all the scripts compile so that's great
we installed it correctly and now if you
open up
command B
you see all of these modules that are
right here
so something that I'm actually going to
do is take this and I'm going to hold
down shift and then click this so I get
all of these and I'm going to move these
back a folder
so what we want to basically do is in
GitHub desktop
you'll see in here all of these folders
all of these dependencies all of these
elements that we're going to push to get
I want them to all be tracked at the
same root level as opposed to having
going into a subfolder to then access
the repository this is just how I
structure my projects and we can then
delete this subfolder because we don't
need it anymore and there we have it so
now we have our project bootstrapped
with the next JS template
for perspective I'm using the latest
next 13 build with react 18 and this is
typescript 4.9 so these are all of the
dependencies that the next JS create
next app project will build for us
the next thing that we're going to do is
we are going to allow a way for our next
JS with typescript project to use Styles
components as our Styles framework so
personally I use style components for
all of my projects because if you
understand CSS this allows us to create
basically functional components for all
of our Styles so that we can replicate
our templated components throughout our
entire project it makes it super easy to
read a lot of visibility across the code
base and it makes it really easy for
anyone to just go in and edit Styles
replicate or duplicate files for
components it just makes it really
really easy and it's very very
accessible to get started so something
that we're going to do is we're going to
add in a DOT Babel RC file and this is
what we're going to allow for our custom
Fable file so we're going to have a
preset of next slash Babel and then in
terms of plugins we're going to have the
Styles components plug in with SSR is
true and display name is true something
else that we're going to do we're going
to edit our next config file so I'm
going to copy and paste these elements
and then I will walk through
how we'll do it so we're basically going
to overwrite
this whole file with this file
so I'll walk through each part of it
and also if you ever see me wrapping the
text I'm doing alt Z on a Mac this is
the command to wrap the text to the
window so what we're doing is we're
creating our next config
and then
we have react strict mode is false under
the compiler we're going to be including
Styles components and then there's going
to be various different files that we
need to install so displaying needs to
be true SSR needs to be true founding
needs to be true top level import paths
we just leave that as an empty array
and then meaningless file names just put
in as index CSS prop is true namespace
is an empty string Minify as false
transpile template literals is false and
then pure is false and what we do is we
set module.exports equal to that next
config that we have up here so this is
that next config file that we need to be
able to allow our build environment to
understand what style components are
trying to do so we're going to save this
and in case you're new to Styles
components I just want to give a little
bit of an overview on what we're doing
uh just because when we're installing
this design framework into the code base
it might be helpful to just have a
little bit of an intro into that before
you start installing you know maybe
things that you haven't used before you
don't know what they do so if you go to
stylethedashcomponents.com this is a lot
of very helpful documentation about how
this styled framework works but
basically what I really like about it is
what you'll see right here so let's say
that we wanted to define a button and
this is going to be a button with a link
around it so now what we'll be able to
do is very easily create this component
that has a styled a tag which we'll use
as a link and then we could you know
Define the Border radius which is three
pixels the padding which is 0.5 from we
have a margin we have width we have
background color border we have all of
these things but where it gets even
cooler is we can also pass properties
into this button similar to a functional
component in react so this is really
great because if you ever have Dynamic
Styles and let's say that something
triggers something else or you have a
loading state but as soon as the loading
state is complete then you want to turn
the button green for example because the
data is ready or let's say that there's
an error and you want to turn the button
red well you'd be able to actually pass
properties down through this component
through the Styles components framework
to then edit those properties so this is
an example where the property is primary
so you would add this as passing data as
props through the component on the
client side and then you would be able
to then edit the background and the
color based upon the property and what
it is doing
and you'll see also here that there's a
ton of companies that are using Styles
component you know Target Vimeo Vogue
Lego you know Autodesk so many different
types of companies BBC Gizmodo take
Master price on right all these
companies change.org Bloomberg I mean
the list the list goes on coinbase the
list goes on so many different companies
are using South components because it
makes it so easy to edit your Styles and
also think about it like this you'd be
able to then copy and import this button
component throughout your entire code
base so anytime that this button exists
you don't have to rewrite a bunch of
inline Styles or you don't have to keep
rewriting CSS modules every time that
you know you need to render a button you
could literally just import this
specific button from your file which
which I'll get to in a little bit and
you'll be able to use this button
throughout your code base which saves
you so much time and it's really
efficient because it's the same code you
don't have to rewrite code and be extra
verbose it's the same code the same
component you define it once and then
use it as many times as you want and
these are just some other examples if
you ever want to check it out but what
we're going to be doing is we're going
to install
with styled components and then we'll
also be installing the Babel styled
components plugin in the dev
dependencies so that will be able to
then which talks about right here
um just so that it can give some more
benefits like legible class names
server-side render compatibility also
smaller bundles and more optimizations
which is really great so we're going to
do that right now
so we're going to open up our code base
here
we're then going to close out that side
header and then we're going to paste
that in here so now that we have npm
install save style components
we're going to install that there
next what we're going to do is
it told us that
we also have styles components payable
[Music]
so you'll see in a little bit why this
is a really helpful plug-in for our Dev
dependencies when we're building with
stealth components so I'm just going to
copy that here
so it's npm install dash dash save Dev
IL plugin style components
let me install that there
and now if we see our code base
it should look like this so dev
dependencies has be able to plug install
the components there and then styled
components exists in our
dependencies there
so whenever you're changing the server
or different elements of the next
config.js or in these other elements
sometimes you'll see this red right
there and it'll say module can't be
found or something like this so one
trick that you can do to get rid of that
red is to
do command shift p
and then when you do command shift p
it'll open up this menu where if you
press or type reload window here
that will help to get rid of the red
error that you might see so this is just
a way to refresh your code base and you
can actually sometimes run this while
you also have a build running so it'll
just refresh the vs code window and
sometimes it'll clear out maybe some
left over it thinks that it needed this
package but it didn't see it so then
it'll just resync up your code base in
vs code to make sure that everything is
consistent so just a fun little hack to
fix that in case you ever see that red
error there or elsewhere related to
typescript or next.js
so once we've edited our next config JS
file we are now going to go into our
index file so under Pages under index
we're going to then remove a few things
that we aren't using anymore so we're
not using this next font module and
there are some instances here where we
reference that but we're just actually
going to start just removing uh these
things so I'm going to take everything
from Main
div all the way down this
and we're going to give that a save
and that is the imported elements that
come in with the template so we're just
getting rid of the template and then
we're going to change the header to be
super quote
generator
cool so once we've changed this header
module this is a module that's specific
to next.js and it allows us to create
Dynamic headers for all of our Pages or
sitewise throughout the application so
this is a great upgrade if you're
familiar with crate react app this is
actually a really really really slick
easy way to do this with xjs and
typescript
so we change this and then this will be
the home page header and let's just
give that a quick save and now we're
going to run this and we're going to see
if this worked out so when we run our
project
in packet.json
you'll see here
under the scripts there's Dev and then
that's those next Dev to start the
project or start which is next start but
we're going to do npm run Dev and that
is what's going to get our project
started up
so see that it was compiling
client and server are successfully
rendered super quickly and now let's see
what that looks like on our browser
when you run npm run Dev that's going to
run our application on localhost 3000 so
this is the URL for how you would get
this in your browser and if you're
running this application so far you
should just see a black screen but in
the header if you hover over this it
should say inspirational quote generator
which is
our title for the header and then if you
were to actually share this link with
somebody else running on our URL which
we'll do in a little bit that's where
you'll see this preview description
where it'll give you a preview of that
you could also have an OG image if you
wanted to add an image as that head
header metadata tag but um we're not
going to do that right now we're just
going to focus on this so just to give a
little bit of a sanity check let's make
sure that this is actually working
correctly so I'm going to just write a
div with hello world inside of this Main
we'll save that and then we'll see that
that is printing and it's actually
updating once we press you know command
s to save it this is going to update in
real time so let's say that we wanted to
say
we'll do an H3 uh tag we'll say great
job running
Js
we'll give that a save and then now
that's actually running and putting it
below so now we see that this is
actually printing out our code which is
awesome so what we're actually going to
do now is we are going to get rid of
this and we're going to start actually
building out the template for our
project with our real code not the
template that is created with create
next app
so we'll give that a save and we'll go
to the next step so let's do some
general housekeeping to set up our
project obviously there's a lot of
styles that the template will come with
but we're going to be creating our
custom code so we want to create our own
Styles so if you navigate to the Styles
subfolder in your project we're going to
go to globals.css and we're basically
going to remove
all of this
so this is just the starter templates
we're going to do a bunch of other stuff
so we're going to install
some fonts and then we're going to
install or basically write some Global
styles so whenever you do
a wild card and then you do these
brackets this is going to be how you
apply basically a general style to all
the pages that ever render So This
Global Styles is basically apply the
style or allow this type of style to
work for any of the projects that or any
of the pages that get rendered in our
project
so we'll do box sizing
water box we'll do padding
zero and then we'll do margin
zero
we also are going to import
some fonts
so I'm going to
copy and paste these in for you to
copy
so where I'm getting these from is
Google fonts these are free fonts that
you are able to access and then use in
your code so I will show you where to
actually search for these so that in
your next projects you're able to
get up and running from that so I'm just
going to do a quick pan just to show you
this last little bit from that font
and then I'll show you
how we get that
so when we want to add a font
you can go to font.google.com and then
let's say that I see Roboto because I
really like this font so you can click
on it and then it's going to give you
all this information about the Styles
the different font family
elements and all the different you know
ways that you know you could be using
this so let's say that I really liked
um this font family for example so what
you can do is that you can obviously
download
or
what you could do is you can just go to
select
you can go to this
and then these are actually the other
fonts that I had in there but what
you'll have is here under Roboto you'll
see that there's a link
and there's also an import so the import
is really important because when you are
working with a framework like CSS we
don't really need to import all this
this is more for like if you're
importing this into HTML we really just
care about this import statement here so
this thing so you'd copy this and then
that's where you would then literally
copy and then paste it into there
right
and that's where you'd be able to copy
um that for example
so same thing here right if you wanted
to do that with Roboto so it seems like
when you you know drop down that's for
this so then this would be for Roboto
yep and then that's how we would add a
font into our CSS so we're going to give
this a quick save and then these Styles
will then apply to our overall project
so then when we go back to this
we'll see now that the background is
white it's not black anymore and some of
these Styles seem to have been applied
which you will see in a little bit back
in vs code we can now
remove our home module CSS these were
just the styles that were
imported from the
create next app we can just delete this
so we'll delete it
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to do a little bit more
organization of our project so when I
work with style components I like to
create a components folder
so I just right click add folder and
then I title it called components and
then we're going to do a folder so we're
going to do
quote generator and there's going to be
also another folder called animations
which we will get to a little bit later
in this video but right now in our quote
generator we're going to not add
anything in there right now but we will
in a little bit we're going to do mainly
all the Styles in our
index.tsx file but we will also add some
sub components to break up our code and
make it more composable through our
project
so now we're going to do is
we're actually going to get started
building out our project so what we want
to do is we want to build out a
background so something that personally
I like to do
is have a file in our quote generator
we're going to call this quote
reader elements
TSX
so when we are working without
components something that I personally
like to do is on the right have our
element and then
on the left we have the actual file that
we're editing in you'll see a little bit
why this makes a lot of sense in terms
of building but a lot of it is just an
organizational thing of I'm editing this
style and I'm adding it into this page
here
so what we're going to do is we want to
add a background to our project we want
to you know give it uh you know a cool
nice you know dynamic background
so how exactly would we go and do that
so what we're going to do is we are
going to
add in a few things so we want to do
background
for our project
so in here
right from the top we are going to do
input styled
from
style to components
we're then going to import link
from next link because we're going to
need this a little bit later
and then we're also going to import
image from next
image here we're going to do is we are
going to use the styled component
extension and if you don't already have
this
you can see the ones that I have so
I like vs code it's syntax highlighting
and then also Styles component Snippets
for vs code these are the ones that I
use and they are super super helpful
because what we can do is if we want to
just write uh basically a snippet for
our style component we'll do exsc
we'll export a stout component and then
we'll call it gradient
background con
and then we need to call it styled
something so we do style div so you
could do styled H1 you could do style H2
you could also do a style of link as
you'll see before you'll see a little
bit later but what we're going to do
here is I'm just going to bump up that
just a little bit just so you can see a
little bit more of the screen
and immediately as we start writing in
Styles components we might start to see
some Type errors
or typescript not recognizing what we're
trying to do so we see this error where
it says can't find the Declaration file
for module stealth components
um basically this has an any type so it
gives a recommendation of let's run the
install for Dev dependencies with types
for styled components and this will
allow typescripts to recognize that we
have style components being used
throughout our project so what we'll do
is we'll open up a new terminal window
and if you don't already have this open
you can do control and then tilde and
that's how you can toggle the terminal
at the bottom of the screen we'll do
I did Ctrl C and then control V we'll do
npm I dash dash save Dev type Styles
components we will install this
for our project
so that ran and then
this error should go away which is great
so now it recognizes that this module
you know checks out with all the types
and it recognizes that that's what we're
doing which is awesome so now we want to
do is we want to add in some Styles here
so I will go through these and then I
will go through them together
cool so just to go through these
background we are giving this a linear
gradient and this is going from one
color to the next color and we have it
going to the right so this is a great
way to and I'll show you the process for
how to do this but this is a really
great way to add that Dynamic you know
styling for any div or any background or
any block where you can you know give it
just this background color but it's a
one color that blends into the next
color and this is like very modern very
you know futuristic it's what a lot of
very like you know really polished apps
will have in that linear background so I
really like linear gradients I like
adding gradients to a lot of things that
I do so that's a great way to add the
background we'll then do background size
a 400 percent
with 400 and what we're going to be
doing is we're going to have this
oscillating effect for the background
and you'll see how having this
background size being really expanded
and then we'll be making it
um basically like moving back and forth
and having it you know move left to
right which you'll see uh through this
animation that we're going to build out
so then we're going to do an animation
to gradient we'll do six seconds e is
infinite
and this is going to basically mean that
we're gonna we haven't created this yet
but we're gonna have a animation called
gradient it's going to be running every
six seconds and it's going to have this
ease effect throughout and it's going to
be running infinitely we'll then do a
height
and then a width of 100 view with
and then what is so awesome about Styles
components you don't have to you know
like start writing you know keyframes
because usually with CSS you'd have to
do like keyframes gradient and then
you'd have this you know in the
background and then you have to
reference it you literally can wrap all
of these elements together and you don't
have to worry about having you know a
certain element being there
um also just with you know doing hovers
let's say that you have this class here
so you'd have to like declare it as like
this with a style and then you'd have to
do something like this with hover and
then do that and you know I I just like
think that style component just makes it
so much easier to just wrap all of your
Styles all of your animations all of
your keyframe editor elements all in one
package component so that you can then
import this throughout your entire
project which I just like I think that's
amazing and it saves you so much time
for having to do all this guesswork of
you know did I have this keyframe is
this keyframe imported did I add this
hover effect you know did I add this
other effects with these Styles so it's
just super easy we'll add then a
background position which is going to be
zero percent to 50 percent
we're then going to do a 50 percent
and then we're going to do another one
and I think Amazon code whisper already
knows exactly what I'm going to do
because I already have this project
committed but we'll just carry out this
other process and then we're basically
going from 0 to 50 to 100 and we're
going from background position you know
zero to 100 back to zero percent and um
we know we're keeping fifty percent for
both so we're adjusting the you know the
height and the width and you know
editing it that way so this is great so
we'll give this a save so this is going
to be really cool in one second but just
to show you also the power of South
components we have this
styled component that we've already
created it's a div with all of these
Styles which is great but how do we
actually get this back into our project
so something that we can do which I
think is so so so awesome so we're going
to declare this almost like we would
declare a div so we use that you know
that carrot and then we're going to just
start typing the name of that styled
component that we just typed so gradient
background and we already see that it's
finding this element so we can just
press enter and now check this out so as
we close this out
it's now added imported this
so this is what it will actually look
like so it's importing from components
code generator coordinator elements and
we'll add this so this is what's awesome
about solid components also is that as
you create you know these unique named
elements we can then just start writing
them as if they were a normal div and
then we'll be able to then you know use
the sort of intellisense of finding the
different names of the components we'll
then be able to import that directly
right into our code it's super fast and
then when we save this check this out
we now have this really really really
cool Dynamic background for our app
which I mean this is like adding that
type of animation with the gradient just
gives it like such a nice Snappy Dynamic
fun vibey element to the project and
this is where you'll be able to add this
really nice linear gradient oscillating
background to our project so that's
great so now you've just seen how to
import the style component and then add
that into one of the pages in our
project so we see that we have a
gradient background component that we
really like so once we've added this
feature one of the best practices that
you can get into is making sure that you
commit this specifically to GitHub so
that you have version Source control so
what we're going to do is in our
GitHub desktop client we see all the
changes that were added and specifically
if we open up this 100 components we see
that gradient background container
Styles component that we have so we
really like this so what we're going to
do is we're going to
keep this on the main branch but we need
to publish this Branch first so what I
like to do is just simply add and we'll
say
added
gradient background container
SC for South component
so that's good so we'll Commit This to
Main and this is all of the different
styles so this was basically our entire
front end application minus you know
node modules and certain elements that
we don't want to push to GitHub because
that would be sending like thousands of
files and we don't want that in our our
GitHub repository because that'll be
built with our package.json if we run
our application you know with a server
but we don't want to put that into the
actual assets that are deployed because
that's what package.json includes so
that's
this file this file right there so these
are all the build scripts and everything
but our dependencies for our build
script but we don't need to include the
node dependent known modules
dependencies packages so what we'll do
is we'll Commit This to Main
we'll publish this
and then we'll wait a second and then
we'll check GitHub to see where they are
so what's awesome about GitHub is as
soon as we push this code and we're able
to push this to our Branch when we
refresh
we'll see all of the code that was just
added to our code repository so when we
go here to our components folder and
then to that component that we just made
we see that the gradient background here
is actually the same that we just added
here so this is a really cool way where
you're able to add that Source control
or Version Control for your application
so if you ever need to for example go
back to a previous commit you can always
go back here and then go back to that
specific commit and then maybe go back
to a previous version this is really
great if you ever need to you know check
out a feature or a certain build or a
certain way in which you built something
you always have that type of History so
this is just a good best practice to get
into when you're building especially if
you're building a new system and maybe
you write some code in maybe there's an
error or maybe just you need to you know
undo something you can always go back to
a previous version and then
just sync up you know and go back to a
certain branch and then you could just
change your code and then GitHub desktop
will be able to switch out the right
code for you now that we've worked with
Git and GitHub and pushed our initial
commit let's now switch back to our code
and let's start building out some of
this front end so what I wanted to do
was add a background to this which we
did which was that gradient but now
let's add some images to the background
just to you know add some Cloud flare so
what we're going to do is we are going
to take these two images
that I have stored in assets
so I create a folder called Assets in
the root so I'll just do right click and
then I'll do add folder I'll say assets
and then I'm going to drag and drop
these that I have stored locally you
could actually use any images that you'd
wish
but these were two that I thought were
kind of fun one was lightning and then
another one was cloud with sun now
that'd be kind of fitting because of
cloud so what we're going to do is we're
going to
create two different components
one is going to be for an image to be in
the top left and one is going to be to
an image in the bottom right so what
we'll do is
we're going to do background
image one
and that's going to have a source
which we'll call
cloud
S one
and that will have a height of 300
and then there's an alt
cloudy back ground
one
we'll close it out and to get rid of
this error we're going to actually need
to create this style component so in our
quote generator elements text file so
that's this we're going to keep our
style components in this and then we'll
import them here
so we'll do exsc which is that expert
size component
snippet and then we are calling that
background image one
this is going to be a styled image
and we already imported image from the
next image
module from reversell and then we're
going to do another different
style so we're going to do position
relative we're going to do Z index one
margin left
minus 120 pixels
margin top
probably just 10 pixels
cool we'll give that a save
and now what we do is
because we already have it for Auto
Import so it'll find this and then we
just need to import Cloud one so we'll
go to the top of our file
and sometimes I like to separate these
different elements so
these will be our components
and then these will be our
assets let's import
classes and it's already finding this
from here
which is awesome
so
that also if you ever want to check if
you hold down command or control
you can always see that but we know that
this is uh mapping to this image that's
there locally so if we ever need to go
and find it we can just go to that check
where it is
and then find where assets are so
we already saved that we'll give this a
save and then we should see this image
there but if it's not finding it that
means that clouds one is not there so
that's because we imported the wrong
file so it actually doesn't know what
our cloud is which our Cloud one object
is so one thing that we can do that'll
actually make it a little bit easier is
if you do dot dot
we can then go to assets and click on
that go drop down
and it should give us a drop down of
what's there
but sometimes if we sort of try to write
it it'll prompt to find what's there so
we want
cloud and Thunder
and then we should see it there so this
is really cool but we see that
it's not aligned in the way that we want
so what we can do is we can go to
elements in the browse and this is I'm
actually pressing F12 so that's how you
open up the dev tools
we'll open up elements
and then we take this selector
we hover over that and then now we can
actually get all of the
the styles for this so the Styles
component is going to create this kind
of dynamically generated you know class
name but we can do is we can move
this there
so
can always move it and what's really
cool about that is let's say that we
give it you know minus 10 something like
that
so now
when we move this it's going to be super
Dynamic and it's going to stay so this
is a great way to debug your code and
your Styles as you're building
so we're going to do is we're going to
switch that out
and then we're going to just close this
out and this should stay in place
because it'll be all relative here and
that's exactly what we're looking for so
this is great so we'll give this a save
okay this is save
and then we'll give this a refresh and
we see that it worked
so that's great awesome so
next up we're going to do the same thing
here but we're actually going to just go
back to our
code generator element
we're going to just copy this we're
going to
just create another one but this is
going to have a different set of styles
we're going to call
this position fixed we're going to do
same thing Z index one we're going to
actually move this all the way to the
right so this is now going to be locked
to the right and then bottom is going to
be -10 so give that a save
and then we're going to do the same
thing here
but we're going to do clouds two
and we're going to basically copy the
same thing here
do clouds too
and
we're gonna do cloudy weather and that's
the second image that's there
we'll give that a save and we'll see
where the saved it so I see that
this added this here but something that
we can do is
if we
refresh
we open this up because this is that new
image that we got
so what I want to do is I want to
change instead of this we're going to
then see that this should be at the
right
and this should be at the bottom bottom
so if that does not do anything for you
then this means that we need to
change this to be that different
component that we just created
so we'll do two we'll import that
we'll save that and now we have that
there which is great and we can actually
maybe make this a little bit more to the
right
I see that that could be just a little
bit more there
so that's looking good but let's just
just see if that actually is the case
okay I like that so that stays right
there
and it's in that fixed position which is
there so I like that so we're gonna do
minus 120
and then we'll just check to see if that
actually worked
and it did that's great okay and then
this stays at the left
and you'll see that that's still it's
it's all kind of adjusting there okay
perfect so this seems really cool and
these are ways where you can work on the
Styles and then also use that F12
elements and then selector to then find
Styles and then edit them in your
browser and then move them back to vs
code so you have them uh as you work on
your components
all right so the next part that we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
generating a footer so that as quotes
are generated our server our serverless
server in the cloud is going to be
adding plus one to the number of quotes
that are generated in a dynamodb uh
table object and then we'll be able to
display that
in the front end so what we're going to
do is we are going to create in our
index.ts x file we're going to create a
footer container
which will be a styled component we're
then going to create this div component
here so that it can go inside we're then
going to have quotes
generated
with a number that will be dynamically
generated we're going to call a number
of quotes which is a value that we're
going to store in use state with the
react you state hook we're then going to
add our breakpoint and then
we're going to do is we're going to say
developed
with we're going to pass in a heart
by and I'm going to do footer link
and this footer link is going to include
some data so I'm going to include an
href
to my YouTube channel so when we and
this is going to be a style component of
a link
component from next but what we're going
to do is you could obviously include you
know maybe your own website or maybe
your own YouTube channel if you have one
uh or in your Instagram or LinkedIn or
something like that but we're gonna have
a call to action and we want to make
this link open up in another browser tab
so we're going to do is we're going to
say Target
we're going to then include underscore
blank
we're then going to
save Rel and then we're going to have
two values here for security so no
opener and no
refer and this helps with Legacy
browsers in terms of some web
vulnerabilities just to make sure that
when you open up this new
tag that you can't have basically like
no elements this will actually like if
you actually open this up or you even
ask chat GPT it'll give you more data
about it but basically this is just if
you're opening up in another tab from
your own website from your own origin to
something else you just want to make
sure you have those values a part of the
link script and then we need to have
some value in here so I'm going to
include a link to my handle but you
could have your own link to your own
handle or your own name if you want to
have it there
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to close it out which we do
and then we're going to start hammering
away on these values I'm going to
actually rename this to be footer
container and then in our quote
generator elements
styled components file we're going to do
exsc for that styled component
snip it we're going to then say footer
container this is going to be a div
and then we're going to start plugging
away on these Styles so we're going to
do is we're going to give this a width
of 100 view with so it'll span the
length of the the width of the screen as
it expands and contracts for the height
we're going to say that this is 50
pixels
tall say text align we're going to say
Center so that all the text is in the
middle
for font family
we're going to say that this is source
code Pro
and then mono space
we're then going to say font size is 15
pixels we're going to give this a
position of absolute
we're going to put this at the bottom
and append it there with zero and then
color is going to be white for the text
and then Z index
is going to be 99999 so that it'll be
prioritized above any other divs in the
screen now to import that we just have
to rewrite the last letter press enter
to add footer container and then now
it's added to our list of imports
automatically which is awesome now to
get this value here so we're going to do
is we're going to be storing this number
of quotes value in a hook called use
state so the way to use State works is
with react you'll have basically a value
you'll set that value as like as well as
in its array basically but it's an array
of a value and then a set value function
or caller and then that equals basically
you state like that so we're going to do
is we're going to say const
we're then going to
copy that value here
and then we're going to say
set because it's basically it's going to
be this
so we set number of quotes we do you
state and we use zero but it's going to
complain because we don't have the right
typing for this value because we're
using typescript so we need to make sure
that we are typing everything correctly
so we're going to do is because this is
a number
could you use a state call this a number
or
can be null
and
have this value here
and then that will be there so
as we can expand this out so
you state
number Boolean
and then we just need to import
you state from react so import
react and then use state
frog react
so then that is how we'll be able to
then call this number and we're going to
automatically set it to be zero so every
time that it loads we're going to hide
we'll show you how to hydrate this data
with function calls from Dynamo but we
don't need to worry about that right now
and then for the footer link
we're going to do another component
style component here
let's expand this out do exsc
do footer link equals styled link
there we go and then what we're going to
do is we're going to overwrite it so
these are going to be
how we override the link so usually the
link will be purple if you've ever seen
that or blue with an underline but we're
going to change it so the color of the
text is white but it'll still have that
URL underscore and then what we'll do is
we'll import Link in that same way so
that as we save this and as we save this
we'll be able to then
check that out and it seems that there's
going to be just one call that we are
missing here
oh I see
we just had that spare function there
okay cool
so I'm going to give this a quick save
and then we should be able to see
this right here so if I expand this a
little bit more for you all so you can
see so what we're doing is we're going
to do quotes generated and that value is
at zero and then it's going to be
developed by developed With Love by and
then this will open up uh my own YouTube
channel but you see how it opens up in
another tab
that's where we're able to have the
blank with the no opener no referrer uh
relative values there and then that's
how you open that up in the in the URL
so what we want to do is I just want to
make this instead of being a white heart
let's make it a red heart so we go back
to the front end
and something that we can do is if you
want to edit
something in line so you don't add a div
where it messes up spacing or add break
points you can use something called span
and what we're going to do is I'm going
to create a
span called red span
I'm going to put that around the heart
and I'm going to put that in our quote
elements quote generator elements here
do exsc we'll do that and then what
we'll do is we will
call it same thing here so red span will
just take away the
Arrow brackets
we're going to make this style slash
span
and make this look a little bit bigger
and then color
will overwrite to be red we'll give that
a save we'll then do the same thing
backspace and hit enter
rewrite and then enter and then we'll
press save and then what we'll see here
when we go back to the front end is we
see that it's red so that's also a way
where we're able to change Styles in
line and also just speaking of styles
being in line so remember when we
changed the color of this Styles
component the text to be white well if
you actually undo that you'll see that
it is that purple you know bluish URL
color that we would expect for URLs also
if you ever want to remove the underline
something you could do is text
decoration
and then go down to none
and then that's how you'll be able to
you know overwrite certain styles that
come with a link that you might expect
but I do think that the the white is
fine because then that we can keep the
color cohesive but I do think that we do
need that underline but just showing you
that that's another way where you could
overwrite the Styles if you ever wanted
to Okay cool so that that's pretty good
and then let's just look at use State
and what that's doing so when we assign
this value to be zero so every time that
this function really it's a functional
component but every time that this page
or this functional component page
loads there's going to be a base value
that is assigned to this thing so let's
say that we want to make it 200. so
every time that this loads it's going to
be 200. load it again you'll see that's
200. we ever wanted to make this you
know
400 we'll give that a save
and now it's 400.
we go back to zero
we give that a save
you refresh and now it's at zero so it
makes sense when you are fetching data
from a server or from your Cloud
environment or from AWS or you know
really anything you really want to make
sure probably that the value is zero or
it's set to basically nothing and then
you hydrate it with data so for us and
our sake we probably just want this to
be
its original value as zero and then
we'll use something called use effect to
hydrate this data with
actual
an actual number from our database so
that's great so now that we've added
this footer component we can proceed to
the next part which will be a pop-up
modal with a button and we'll start
configuring out how the front end Works
to get that modal pop-up that we want
for a component so that we can start
clicking and getting our quotes one of
my absolute favorite Frameworks to use
is material UI they have a lot of these
components that you can you know spin up
and then you know use however you like
but I really like their modal component
because it's just so easy you can have
this element here and then just have
this pop up and you can actually just
use this modal
you know really as like its own
component you don't necessarily need to
click a button you could just have it
open and then it sort of just fills over
this so as something expands you still
have the modal over that screen so I
really like that and we're going to be
using this in our application so what
we're going to do is we're going to use
npm to install these packages so I'm
just on the mui.com material UI such
getting started installation and that's
where we'll be installing the mui
material emotion react and emotion
styled
elements here so we go back to our code
base
we will open up another tab so we want
to keep that running there
we will do clear
we're going to then install these into
our package.json
script and then these will install these
packages in our node modules
and then we'll be able to start building
out our
element
so there's gonna be quite a lot of code
that we are going to build here so let's
dig in
so when we are configuring our
front end what we really want is we want
to have
this
background which we already have
gradient background right these images
are just going to stay
in the background so we'll just start
labeling some of this stuff so it'll be
background
images
and then
we'll say footer
and that stays there so now we want to
do is we want to push
some stuff uh basically over these
images
and we're going to build basically quite
a lot of things so we're going to have
a quote
generator modal
and then we're going to basically have
this as a modal and then we're going to
have some stuff over it so we're going
to create a component called gradient
quote
generator
modal
and that is just going to be the pop-up
as we call our script but we don't
necessarily need to worry about that
right now we're just going to comment
that out and we'll worry about that
later the next thing that we're going to
do is we are going to and I'm actually
going to indent these just a little bit
easier to see
something that we are going to build out
next is
quote generator modal actually we'll
call it modal pop-up just so that it's
easy to see
and then this is the code generator
and that's going to be the button that
we call so we're going to need to have a
quote
generator container we're then going to
want to have a quote generator
inner container
then we're going to want to have a quote
generator title
and this is going to be daily
inspiration
generator
the title
we're then going to have a subtitle so
that's going to be quote
generator subtitle
and then
I'm just going to copy this text in
under the subtitle here
and I'll just do that so
I just thought it would be you know a
fun you know description of looking for
a slash of inspiration generator code
card with transformational quote card
generated by and then I have again that
same footer link component that's the
link component style link component that
we referenced earlier in the footer
I linked to Zen quotes and then I list
the Zen quotes API and I sit there so
just to give a little bit of a
perspective ons and quotes
so what they are they are a really easy
to use API you can use it for free they
also have a you know a paid version if
you ever were needing you know like a
lot of requests but uh with this is just
uh you know just like a a project that
we're building out so we don't need to
use you know an API key or anything like
that so what we're able to do is just
use
their API their URL to then call the Zen
quotes API and then get a random quote
back so these are some of the people
that you can get quotes from and then
you could also you know browse quotes by
keyword they just have a lot of built-in
functionality and it's really easy to
just
you know hit this API and which we'll do
in a little bit and then actually
generate a random quote so pretty cool
and we'll show exactly how to do that
but yeah major shout out to Zen quotes
for providing this free utility for
random quotes
so that's how we're going to be getting
our random quote and I'm just giving you
know accreditation twos and quotes for
providing this as a service
next up we're going to create a button
so under
subtitle we're going to create a button
so we're going to do
generate quote button
and then we're going to include some
button text so we're going to do
generate
quote button text
and that's going to have an on click
function but we're just going to make
that
go to a null function just for now just
as a placeholder
this is going to say make a quote
and then that's the text
that's the button that closes it out we
got the inner container and then we have
that
so that's pretty much all that we have
here and I'm just going to move these
out just a little bit
just for spacing's sake and now we can
start attacking some of these components
so what we're going to do is
we're then going to start going to these
from the top so there's gonna be quite a
lot of styles that we're going to be
referencing in this so that's why we are
going to have split screen
so there's a style that is becoming
really popular with a lot of you know
like Innovative Tech Cutting Edge tech
companies called glassomorphism and I
found a really great website that I'm
going to show in a second but this is
how I'm going to be getting the
inspiration to style these different
components so if you go to hype4.academy
they have this glassomorphism generator
for making basically the styles for a
div so it's really awesome because what
you can do is you can adjust the
blurriness so you see sort of this
background image gets blurrier
can also adjust the transparency so how
transparent something is
so if you had like no blur and then it's
transparent you can kind of see over it
or if you want to add the image and then
you add blur you can see how it's
adjusting those ones and you can also
make it a different color so if you want
to make it red let's make it blue
I want to make it you know like
different types of colors of the rainbow
you could do that and then you could
adjust the blurriness adjust
transparency and then you just copy the
CSS here and then you could import those
directly into your application so we're
going to be using those types of styles
with
a few twists
so the first one that we're going to
create is the quote generator container
so exsc
for our style component we do
co-generative container and then this is
of course going to be a div
and then we're going to be copying a
whole bunch of these Styles here
which I'll just copy to save some time
so we have a Min height of 350 this is
going to be
creating the height and the width we'll
then do
um basically like a minimum height and a
minimum width and then just a height and
a width so this is as the screen is
expanding or decreasing we're going to
be having sort of this minimum bound and
then this upper bound to work within and
then we're going to have a border of two
pixels we're gonna have a border radius
to round out the edges and then we're
going to be putting this in the middle
of the screen so this is in the middle
of that background that has the
animation of the color switching and
then we to actually get this to
go exactly in the center we're going to
do top 50 left 50 and then we do this
transform translate manipulation of
minus 50 minus 50 with a position
absolute so this is a way that you can
Center a div within a div so it's a
pretty handy trick and then Z index is
going to be above the background and
then this is that glassomorphic style so
this is a specific uh you know shade of
dark Indigo purple and then this box
Shadow will sort of
add kind of this like glassy outer
effect
we then have this backdrop filter which
is a blur and then a backdrop filter as
well which is a blur and then border
radius of 10 to round out the edges and
then we have a border there so this is
that style for the quote generator
container we're then going to do as I'm
sure you guessed it rewrite that import
with enter then we're going to do the
next one we're going to do
exsc again
we'll put this one in there we're going
to do div
and then we're going to
add some more Styles in here so for this
one
we're going to do top 50 left 50 again
that transfer and translate manipulation
position absolute with 100 so what we're
doing is we have this background we're
creating this in the middle of that and
then we're going to then have another
div in the middle of this and you'll see
why we layer it this way but sometimes
if you want to have something centered
within something that's also centered
this is a way that you can have a div
within a div over another div and then
that's how you can
have more of these balanced
Styles and ordering so again we import
that directly there now for the title
I'm going to do exsc again we'll do that
for the title
for title again it's going to be style
of div
and we're going to be copying some more
Styles here
and what we're doing here is we are
making the font family this permanent
marker font size of 50 text align make
the text in the center there's going to
be a color
for text being white we're going to have
this padding of you know 0 20 pixels
0-20 pixels and you'll see why that
padding matters and also for the
position we're going to have that
relative so it's going to be you know
centered at the top and then if the
screen has a max width of 60 pixels then
the font size is going to decrease by 20
pixels so it's going to go from 50 to
30. and that's really important because
when you have screens changing you also
have to think about how readable is the
text and you might need to make
something smaller you might need to make
something you know go on a second line
so these are just considerations and
what this is called is a media query
so send it in some media query so what's
awesome about Stealth components is that
you can have these media queries wrapped
into these different components and then
you could have this all Impact
everything that's within this div which
is awesome
so now we will import this
which is great now we just need to work
on the subtitle so we'll do exsc again
we'll get subtitle
and we're going to add some more Styles
here
this of course is going to be another
div
which is there and then text color is
going to be white font family caveat
font size is 35 position is relative
width is 100 text align Center padding
similar Styles except now this is going
to be a little bit smaller so we're sort
of making this as subtitle text which
has a different font and is also smaller
and then we will import this we will
import
that
like that
and then we're going to work on this
quote button
so e x s c again redo this we'll make
another div
and I'm sure you probably guessed it
that we could be just using a button but
I do like styling
these in a custom way just because it
gives you a little bit more granularity
of what you're doing with the Styles and
it gives you a little bit more control
so there's quite a lot of styles going
on to this button but at a high level
we're going to be having some
glossomorphic effects here which you
know you might recognize from the top
before but we're going to give the
button
100 pixels as the height 300 pixels as
the width is going to be a border around
them there's gonna be a border radius
margin top is 20 pixels so that makes it
a little bit
um down from the top there's gonna be a
position relative there's a transition
so this is what we're going to be doing
so as there's a hover effect we want to
be using this 0.2 second
ease in ease out effect
when you hover over it or basically when
you want to click on it we're going to
have this pointer
now so we're going to change from you
know just like the normal clicker to a
pointer
um it's going to be top 20 pixels and
then the margin is auto transform origin
is Center so this is how we're going to
be centering this inside of the div
and then we give this this glossomorphic
effect so that's these Styles here
so you know pretty similar to the other
ones that were above and then the on
Hover so this is how you do on Hover
effects and styled component so
when you do that so that you apply this
class and then you have a filter there's
a transition there's a transform so it's
going to get a little bit bigger as you
hover over it the brightness is going to
increase by three times and there's also
this will just stay in the center
so we will import this
and then we just need to do the text and
that should round out the last of our
Imports for style components so again
exsc
we're gonna do button text
so this is going to be the text that's
inside of the button that's centered so
we're going to do div
once more
and then
we're going to
give this some Styles so the text color
is going to be white font family is
going to be caveat uh font size is going
to be 35 pixels we're doing that left
top transform Translate
uh you know star manipulation to make it
in the center with a position absolute
the width is going to be 100 and that's
going to be that the text div is 100 of
the button that it's within and then
this hexa line is centered so the text
is going to be in the center
so we'll import that
and it's probably not going to like the
fact that we have on click but that's
okay for now
we'll see if typescript complains about
it too much
but hopefully should be
able to be okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
switch back to our previous window here
and let's see what we got
so this is starting to look like a real
application so what I really like about
this glossomorphic effect is that as we
make this smaller this becomes much more
Dynamic and this is really clean I think
if you are building you know portfolio
projects or anything for work being able
to show this level of detail to your
build I think is hands down game
changing because it also shows that
you're really thinking about as the user
is on different devices especially
considering how mobile we all are being
able to have that consideration around
styles to say hey we have this desktop
application but then we can also make it
mobile these are skills that will pay
dividends down the road for you and of
course we see that on Hover effect that
looks really clean and as we hover over
the colors changing there's that little
bit of glow and of course we see that
and if we open up Zen quotes we see how
it opens up in another tab
which is exactly what we wanted to do
with that Target blank and this is
looking pretty cool so far so again we
got that glossomorphic effect where it's
blurring out the images in the corner
and as these move you see that
glossomorphic effect moving over it so
this is looking like an application and
I'm really happy with what we have so
far and as we continue the rest of this
build once we click make a quote we're
going to then have a modal pop-up and
that's going to manage some State and
then that's where we're going to be
interfacing with the cloud and then
getting an image back so you'll see how
we'll do that in the next part of
the build so as we start working on our
full stack project I do think that it's
helpful to do a lot of deconstructionism
when it comes to building out parts or
components so a methodology that I've
found really helpful is using an online
IDE like code sandbox to build out
scripts build out components build out
certain elements before we Institute
that or Implement that into our
application so when we are clicking this
button obviously this button isn't
linked to any functions right now but
when we call this we're going to be
calling our API to run a Lambda script
to do something and then send that back
to our front end so we don't have this
script configured yet but it would make
sense for us to be thinking about this
before we start implementing it because
when we are waiting to get data back
from Lambda we're going to need to have
some sort of use state for based are we
fetching data is something loading did
something complete and did the function
finish running what we called it to do
so this is where it makes sense for us
to sort of Park our front end and then
move to working on the back end and when
we think about deconstructionism what we
can do is that we can create a code
sandbox
IDE it's an online editor but it allows
us to write node.js we could you know
create a Docker instance we could use
Dino view react uh they have rust they
have python they have Astro
T3 app they have next Js
they have almost anything nuxed they
have literally everything you could ever
do they have a node HTTP server view
three
svelte Gatsby like they have remix they
have literally everything so what we
want to do is we want to create what
will become our Lambda server but we
want to test it out in node.js before we
actually start implementing it
so when we do create IDE
we then start this up and what we'll do
is we'll title this so I'm going to name
this
to inspirational quote generator
right there
we'll save that and that automatically
Auto saves
did that there
and then we'll just do a quick refresh
just to make sure that it's saving
correctly which it seems like it is so
now when you spin up your code sandbox
IDE your node.js environment for the
first time you can
run your commands with just refreshing
and it'll rerun the server let's say
that we want to do hello code sandbox 2.
we'll say that too we'll see
hey friends
welcome to this build
we'll give that a save
we'll do refresh
and now we see hey friends welcome to
this build so that means that it's
working which is great so now we're
going to do is we are going to start
getting our hands dirty with building
this script
so just for some housekeeping purposes
we are going to remove this
and now it won't do anything because
we're not calling it to do anything so
what we're going to do is and I do think
that this is a helpful exercise before
you ever write any code for your script
let's really think about what we
actually need the script to do so we're
going to need the script to do a couple
of things but for starters we want to
fetch our random quote
for number two we want to basically turn
those those quotes or that fetched quote
into a series of lines which we're going
to call this quote text so we're going
to turn
text of quote
into lines
which is going to be the quote text
received
and I'm going to make this just a little
bit bigger
the text just so that you all can
see it there
cool now for number three
we want to
basically create a line for our author
so we have the text
which is the uh
I'm just going to make this a little bit
bigger yet so
we will have so we have the lines for
our quote so the quote could be maybe
one line two lines three lines or four
lines and then the author is going to be
aligned after that so you want to turn
text of author into a line
and that's the quote author
then the fourth thing that we're going
to need to do is add a quote image of
some sort so add a quote image
then for number five we want to turn all
of these elements into a renderable SVG
so we turn these elements
into an SVG format
and then to finish off the rest of the
script we want to basically take that
SVG
and then turn that into an image which
we're going to configure an image as PNG
here but we're going to need to have it
as a base 64.
string in Lambda
which we'll worry about later you don't
need to worry about that right now but
what that means is that instead of it
being an actual file it's going to be a
series of characters that will resemble
an image file which we'll get to in a
little bit so that seems to be on track
for what we're looking for and
sometimes I find it helpful also just to
save this in the readme file so if you
want to edit your readme file you can
just go in here we'll switch this out oh
I think that's uh
doing that again so I'll do
inspirational
quote generator app
and then we'll have these as our
readme element and then we'll just give
that a save
we'll switch back to reading so just so
in case we ever need to reference this
back we have the saved in another
another spot
okay so now that we have our steps here
we're going to now start configuring our
server so there's going to be a specific
package that we're going to need to
create and I'm going to create a
terminal
and we're going to make this a little
bit bigger so we're going to need to
install
a couple of things so sharp is going to
be a library that we're going to need
for the image processing so we'll do npm
I sharp and then we'll press enter
and now we should see in package.json
which is the sharp installed as a
dependency which is great means that it
installed correctly and then we're going
to need to install a specific version of
node fetch
which is specifically version two so
we'll do ntmi node fetch at 2.6.2 and
this is very similar to what Lambda is
going to need for this specific way to
fetch data outside of the server using
node.js
so
that is a great way for us to start
working and you'll see here that now
node fetches at 2.6.9
and that means that we have that working
when we're making these images we are
going to want to pull a random set of
colors for the background those are
going to be just a random background
graphic so what we're going to do is
we're going to create so we're going to
right click we'll do nude directory
then we'll call this backgrounds
and then we're going to drag and drop
these that are from my computer here and
we have these different colors that we
drop into here so these are 750 by 500
pixels resolution is 72 by 72 but where
I got these was from this awesome
website called uigradians.com and you
get a ton of really great
different gradients here and um
you can just like pull in different ones
and you can also see
you know kind of like how they're made
how they work and they even have ones
that are like three colors too which are
pretty cool
and
even like that it's pretty sick so
what I did was I just found four that I
really liked and then those became the
backgrounds that I will call in the
script so you can either use those or
pull from your own
but just make sure that it's that 750 by
500 pixel background size
so then when we are working on our
script we're also going to create
another directory and we're just going
to call this finals
and that's just going to be where we
store the images that get generated and
those are going to be all the folders
that we need to create
so what we're going to do just to get
this kicked off
is we're going to call a few things so
we're going to first of all call Sharp
then we're going to call the zenquist
API and then we're going to call fetch
so that we can use node fetch to then
color API so we're going to do these
import statements
at the top now actually I'll just do it
at the top just because it'll be easier
to see so
cut sharp equals require
and we'll call Sharp
const API URL
from Zen quotes So https https
present quotes
dot IO API random and that's the API
endpoint to call Zen quotes's random API
generator
and then const fetch equals require
node
fetch
all right so now we're going to create
an async function
called get random quote
we're going to call this API URL here so
API URL
and then we'll start to create our
function so we're going to create two
variables so first one is going to say
like what is and that's going to say let
quote text
be this variable and then this other one
is going to be
author name here
and then that's going to be let
quote author so it's gonna be the two
variables that will change as we get
data back
so we want to validate
response to the API
in this step
and we're going to do const response
equals
await fetch
API URL which we'll just copy from there
to do our quote data equals away
response dot Json
so we're going to take this response
we're going to turn it into Json data
and then put that into a quote data
variable and then we'll do console.log
quote data
to log that out
and we can actually try to see if we can
call this right now
so what we actually are going to change
is this so I'm just going to call this
API URL input
just to differentiate API URL from there
and there so then
we're going to call
get random quote
with that API
and then we'll see if we can restart
this
so as you can see we are able to get
this data back which is really cool so I
want to
open up screen brush and just show you
how this is working because this is also
really helpful to think about when you
call apis
what is actually happening
so when we have
this data so this is going to be the
quote data so that's quote text right
there then the quote author is going to
be right here
and it actually creates this block quote
you know kind of HTML block for you but
we're not actually going to use that
we're going to take these variables and
use them in our own way but what we're
doing is that you know we're calling
this index.js file and then
we're going to use fetch to use that API
URL input so that's that you know http
Zen quotes you know random API and
that's when we're fetching the data out
of that endpoint and that's going to
they have their own function that's
going to generate from their list of
quote a random one for us to use and
then we take basically that response we
turn it into this Json structure which
you see you know in this so that's that
Json and that's where we'd be able to
take you know dot Q or dot a and then
use those in our
in our graphic which you'll see and then
the this is a specific input so this is
just you know run this function with
this specific input so then we take this
which is the API URL and this is that
API endpoint so it takes given this API
input endpoint input
um API endpoint input there we go we're
able to then fetch that and then create
a response and then map that into some
Json that then we can use in our
application we can actually run this a
bunch of times and we'll get different
quotes
so that was one by Aristotle
this is another one
another one
another one here
we'll do one more so what's really cool
about this is that it's running this
random API generator and that's how
we're able to validate that our get
random quote function is actually
working which is great so now we're
going to keep plugging along with
actually some of the image generation
components as well but now that we have
this function setup we're able to call
that API endpoint and it's working now
we're going to start working on some of
the construction of the image and also
validating the response out of the API
so what we're going to do is we're going
to then
update these quote text and quote author
variables and we're going to say quote
text
equals quote data
that first object dot Q so that's going
to be in the first item right this first
object get the Q variable and then also
quote author equals and we're going to
do that same thing
except make that a
and we can also try logging
these variables just to make sure that
they are in fact working because that'll
be important for us to see so if we do
this we do refresh
so I see that so I see a quote which is
that and then the author is that
we'll do another one
so yeah so it seems like this is what
we're doing so this is going to be
really easy to to see where of course we
have this Json data structure but now we
have you know something that kind of
looks almost like a graphic right you
have your quote and then you have your
author so this all works so we can get
rid of those console log statements
and we can proceed here so now we're
going to construct our image so this is
going to be the image
Construction
and these are going to be the quote
elements and let us just make sure these
these elements are a little bit better
indented here
okay cool
so now under the image construction
we're going to do a variable for width
it's going to be seven
feet
I'm gonna make that a little bit smaller
than the graphic
and then you do const
text equals quote text so the text for
the graphic is going to be that same
variable there
and then we're going to do const words
equals
split we're going to add a space
there and then we're going to be
creating these line breaks so something
that I found that is really important
for this quote was that when I was
generating these initially
this long string oh this is going to
error out
um
I'm actually going to not call anything
so and then it should uh yeah it might
just have an error but that's because I
don't have anything there
so what um what I originally was having
was when I had that string running or
actually we can
comment this out uh comment that out but
keep that running
see if that runs yeah so
where was this yep so in the quote so
you have these lists of words so it
would basically take the string and it
would stretch it across the length of
the graphic off of the um the left and
the right so what we need to do is we
need to be able to map a list of these
words
um basically in lines and then go to the
next line and then map a few words and
then go to the next line so that's where
we're going to be adding some variables
here
so when we do const line break
equals four and then let new text we're
going to be constructing
this
sort of string manipulation so that as
it goes to forwards then it breaks then
it goes to forwards and then it breaks
goes forwards and it breaks so that's
going to be a way where we take
basically this variable which we'll soon
call T span element and then we're going
to do basically this for loop on the
number of words and the length of that
and then increment over it and then
create these line breaks as we go along
so this was sort of a clever way in
which I was able to you know put the
text in the middle of the graphic create
these lines and then iterate over that
so that it's never more than four words
on each line and then it'll you know cut
out after a certain time so you'll see
how we'll do that with this upcoming for
loop with basically an if this then run
this otherwise run this type logic so
we're going to Define some t-span
elements
with four words each
so what we'll do is we'll do let T span
elements
equal
an empty string
then we'll do four and we'll do let as I
equals zero
I is less than words dot length
and then as I increments upwards
we're then going to say the new text
plus equal words
I
so as I is incrementing
we'll add a space
and then if
we'll do I plus one
divisible by line break
line break
equals equals zero
we'll then make t-span element with t
span
elements
plus equal and then we'll do a
back
Tick T span
x equals and then this is where we're
going to be adjusting the width
here
so I'm actually going to like make this
like much smaller just because like we
don't really need this right now I just
wanna
prioritize this for the screen
so t-span and X is going to equal
this variable of
width divided by 2
d y equals 1.2 em
and then
we'll add the new text in there
and then we'll cut out the t-span
element there
and then backticks
is there and then
semicolon is there
so then after that
this new text is going to equal this
empty string there
and then we pass that back and then we
say if new text
does not equal
it's empty string
then t-span elements
plus equals t-span and we're going to
basically call the same thing again so
I'm just going to copy that down here
and it's going to be t-span x equals
width divided by two
Dy 1.2 em
new text and then t-span there so that's
going to be
that construction
and then we're going to console log
the t-span elements just to see if we're
getting this correct
so let's just give this a save and then
let's see how this works
so I'm seeing that there's this t-span a
person without a
then that ends and the new one
sense of humor is
then like a wagon without
Spring stilted by every
Pebble in the road so that's great so
this seems like this is all of the quote
text elements that are all mapped in
these t-span
implements and then it's going to be
every four word so remembering that you
are a
going to die is the best way I
this is all basically four letter words
trap of thinking you have something to
lose
and then confidence comes from Crossing
thresholds and this is just one so this
is really important because when you
have a list of four you then need to
make sure that any remaining words still
go on that new line so that's when
you're able to see
in
this for Loop here we want to make sure
that as there's no more basically line
breaks as in there's no more words that
map to B4 we just add that new element
basically the new text and then we add
our
uh basically these C-SPAN elements but
it's only going to include
one last one which is all the words that
are remaining so that works out great so
this is working which is awesome and
then
we're going to start working on the SVG
image
next up we're going to be creating the
construction of the SVG
so right after console logging those
t-spin elements we are going to
work on I'm going to
just make sure that this is all
habbed correctly
so
the construct
PT
so we'll do cons SVG image
equals it will do backticks here so this
is how we will do the mapping around the
image so this is going to be SVG
with
and I'm actually going to copy some of
this stuff just to make it a little bit
easier to see mapped out so we're going
to have this SVG with this width that's
the same width that we mentioned up here
with a height which we have up there
and then we're going to copy
these styles that we created
here so the way that this is going to
work is that we have basically when you
have an SVG you can include Styles
inside of this image kind of like a div
and it's going to have
these different elements so it's going
to have a title which is going to have a
fill it'll have a font size and it'll be
bold we have this author Style
we then have a footer Style
and
the author is going to be this size it's
going to be bold as well with some
padding and then the footer
which is where we give an accreditation
then we say it's you know it's by us and
then quotes so that's going to have a
different font size it's also bold
different fill and it's going to be in
the middle and that's how we'll be
mapping out all the styles
so next we're going to do is we're going
to now have the elements of the actual
image
so right after Style
and I'm going to just move this over a
little bit there
so then we're gonna have a circle SVG so
the circle SVG is going to have
a quote in there
so this is the fill and you'll see here
that this is where
we'll we'll have a circle at the top of
the screen
then we're going to have some text for
the actual quote so it's going to look
like this but it'll have text
and I'm going to just map over this just
so that you can see it so there's going
to be the circle
and the circle has this positioning we
then have this text
which I will just
span over so you can see
so the text is going to be in the middle
and it's going to be a quote like a
single quote and it's going to have this
font size of now this is going to be
pretty big and it's going to have fun
family and Veranda or verdana and then
the fill is white so it's going to be
this quote over this image and then
that's how that's going to be working
next up
we're going to be working on
the t-span elements being mapped along
with the quote author so that's going to
be this separate section here
which we will put here
and
what we're going to do is I will just
span to show you so we have this
this G element
and this is also
um
going to be some text here so
the text is coming from there
and
what we do is we have this rectangle we
have a width and that's where we're
going to be putting the text inside of
this rectangle and then the text ID is a
little you know the last line of code so
basically we'll have this width
and then
the last line of quote equals that
all the texts in the middle
and then the t-span elements go in there
and then the quote author is going to
go right after that
then we're going to add a little bit
more text here
which you'll see in a second
so right after this G group
we're going to add a little bit more
text here
I'm just going to make the formatting of
this just a little bit easier
see
so then the text for the footer is going
to be that footer Styles so there's
going to be some text it's going to be
the width
with the Y
can actually move this up just to make
it a little bit easier to see
so
in terms of this text we have the width
we have the height
and footer Styles is there and then we
could say developed by and you could put
your you know social media handle or
your name and then we're just giving
this accreditation to send quotes
because they're providing this API for
free so they say to include that in the
graphic which we're doing
so we can stay in compliance with them
so then we're going to be closing out
this SVG
so
well then
say SVG is closed
that is the backtick and the colon
so that's quite a lot just for that SVG
but now we're going to have an image
with a circle with a quote we're going
to have those C-SPAN elements the quote
spanning across the screen down we'll
have the quote author and then we'll
have this footer with our name and the
Zen quotes API
credit two so now we want to do is we
want to add those backgrounds in a
random way so what we're going to do is
we're going to say const or actually
just say that add
background images for the SVG
creation
so now when we do cons background images
equals there's going to be an array and
we're going to copy basically all of the
paths in our backgrounds folder so
that's what these are so these are going
to be the different files and those we
just have four of them so you'll see
here that
that's where they're coming from
and that all looks good
then we're going to choose a random
image here I'm just going to make this
a little bit there if so now when we
want to select a random one we'll do
const random index so pulling a random
index from this list
we're going to use the math dot floor
and then we'll do math dot random number
times
background images
dot length and this is an easy way to
inject some Randomness into
our
function right here
and then we'll do const selected
background image equals background
images
random index
there we go so now the selected
background image is going to be one that
we pick out of the background images
with this random index so we get
basically this random number
for all these different backgrounds and
then we're going to then make that the
index that we select for our background
images and then that will be the
selected background so if you have more
uh you know more backgrounds that you
include here then this number will have
more options to choose more randomly so
you'll probably get you know more
selections obviously from choosing that
so then
we're going to
do some composition so we're going to
composite this image together
so that's gonna be the next step we'll
do const time stamp
equals new
date and this is a way that we can get
the actual date timestamp
local date string which is that method
and then we'll do replace and then
there's this special set of characters
that
help to just make it all you know
basically like checking for these
characters and then if that's there then
just insert that which is an empty
string
which you'll see why that's relevant in
a little bit I'm going to do const SVG
buffer equals and then we're going to
use buffer as a image
transformation Library this will be from
SVG image and that SVG image is coming
from
this SVG that we're creating up there
then we'll do const image equals await
and then we're going to use that short
package if you remember from earlier we
imported that that's from there so now
we're actually going to use sharp to
generate this image so we'll do Sharp
selected background
image
and then we're going to do composite
and then there is
this input
which is SVG buffer
which was that variable that we just
called on line 97
there is a top of zero there is a left
of zero
and
we add some commas
then we're going to do this command
called to file
we're going to say finals
I'm going to say quote card quote card
underscore
dollar sign
timestamp
PNG
and then we have closing bracket
and then we call our API so we're going
to see if
hopefully this all runs and works
correctly so let's see if that actually
does happen
so we'll do running
and seems like we got something so let's
see if this worked
all right so
let me just close this out for a second
and so you'll see here that this is
um this is basically trying to create
this time stamp string
and
this is five uh
five five twenty twenty three so this is
May 5th 2023 so it's just including the
the date
um
so this is a quote by Abraham Lincoln
and that was just generated randomly so
then let us try to
do this again
so we'll try to run it one more time
and
I think we probably want to
have a different time stamp
I do Wonder though
how we can make this just a little bit
differently so I think that's just
because it's date so let's just try to
change it to local string
so two local string replace
and we'll save that and then we'll try
to run that again yeah there we go so
now this is doing it also with time so
this is the date and then also uh
timestamp as well so now we have this
different image and this is you know now
Thomas Edison's this is a different
quote we'll try to run this again
and we'll get a different one
we'll run this again we'll get a
different one
we'll run this again and we'll get a
different one and this is really cool
because now we're able to just make all
of these super super super quickly JRR
Tolkien
we'll keep running here hamster Anderson
and this is awesome so this is
creating this you know this choosing a
random background it's taking this quote
it's mapping everything and it's making
it all in these graphics and these are
all created through
node.js
so pretty cool and we'll just maybe
let's just do one more for good measure
cool and we'll leave on a good note with
Eleanor Roosevelt so happiness is not a
goal it's a byproduct of a life well
lived very well said so this is great so
we have our script now and this is
running this is perfect so now we're
gonna do is we are going to go back to
our code which is here
we are going to 100 save this but it's
pretty much already Auto saving anyway
and we'll just give a look over our code
everything looks great
and yeah now we're going to be able to
take this and then put this on AWS
Lambda
with a little bit of refactoring here
and there and then we'll be able to work
with our front end to call our Lambda
through appsync and then generate this
image
in a serverless Lambda server and then
get that back in the front end but
instead of it being an image we're going
to do something called a basic C4
encoded string which you'll see in a
little bit but that's going to be a
different way in which we actually get
the image generated not as a file but as
a string so it's going to be like a a
ton of characters and that's actually
how we will be able to map our
our image to a string and then decode
that in the front end
now that we have our script to run and
create our image something that we can
now do is go back to the front end
so in our application we're going to
want to set up our Cloud environment
and really set up all the services that
we're going to be using and leveraging
in AWS to then run that script and we're
going to have a series of front-end
listeners uh basically using our API
endpoint to then listen for when we're
generating the quote send a response to
get the quote
quote card and then get that response
back and then show that in the front end
so what we're going to do is
we're going to check out the AWS amplify
documentation so the amplify CLI is a
very powerful CLI for deploying AWS
resources for you know really a full
stack software project and
if you don't already have this installed
I'm just assuming here but you do npm
install
you know G flag at AWS amplify.tli you
can also use a curl command
which
looks like this
and then also if you are on Windows it
would look something like this
and then you'd be able to install it
on any of your devices but since we have
already done this uh we already have the
CLI installed
we don't have to do the step so the next
step if you haven't already done this is
you should configure and amplify IAM
user
or really just an IM user for your
amplify CLI so that amplify service can
build the services that you want in your
cloudformation stack and update your
stack for you so when you add an API
when you add a Lambda when you add
storage when you add a database model
you want to be able to have an IM user
that can update or modify or delete
resources in the cloud formation stack
so I've already created an amplify I am
user with the administer access amplify
specifications but if you haven't you
use amplify configure you'll it'll then
walk you through all these processes but
you'll create the name and then you'll
set the permissions so they have this
administer access amplify policy name
which is a managed policy you attach
that and then you're going to get a key
value pair
to then
go to security credentials where you can
get your access key and then you'll save
that to your AWS credentials file
locally
so when you can retrieve your access
Keys that's where you're going to have
your access key in your secret access
key and that's what will configure
access for your application
or for the CLI to be able to work with
AWS so you'd be entering that in and
then you'd be able to have that user and
then when you run amplify init or
amplify initialize that's where you'll
be able to use this AWS profile to then
launch your project
or launch the cloudformation stack for
your project so what we're going to do
is we're going to go back here we're
going to open up
the terminal and I did this with the
control and then the tilde button and
what we're going to do is we're going to
do amplify init
and we're going to do that because we
haven't already set up amplify in our
project yet we are we're just starting
out here so let's amplify net
and I'll pull this up so it's
recommended to run this from the root of
your project which we
which we are doing here because that's
the root of this project and we're going
to call this
inspo quote gen
or
should we call that maybe in inspiration
quotes
yeah we'll call it inspirational quotes
So then what's really great about the
cli2 is that it already is able to know
quite a bit about my project because
it's checking out what I have so it
knows that the environment is Dev I'm in
Visual Studio code so this is actually
the default environment but it knows
that this is what we're going to want
just to start out with
um it knows that this is the JavaScript
which is the appetite and we're using
react which we are and then there's
going to be a source directory that it's
going to create with this AWS exports
file and then these are going to be the
builds commands so this all sounds great
we'll say yes
and then we're going to use this AWS
profile as opposed to the access key so
I'm going to choose the AWS profile
and I'm going to choose the role that I
have already set up for my amplify
configuration to my AWS account
so I'm going to press that and then it's
going to start deploying these resources
into AWS so it's going to start creating
this cloud formation stack and then it's
going to start deploying this to the
cloud so I'm going to pause the
recording now and then I'll restart it
when the cloudformation stack is all set
up in AWS
now that our cloud formation stack has
been pushed to AWS we just received uh
some new things so let's go through our
application and see what AWS and amplify
provided for us so one of the first
things that we'll see is a new directory
in our route which is called amplify if
we open this up there is a config with
some
local AWS info and some project info
that's just scoped about the project
also the current cloud backend so this
is going to be the updates that you make
locally and then it's going to compare
the current stack local with the AWS
stack in the cloud and then when you are
adding a resource when you're updating a
resource it'll compare the cloud version
with your local version and then that is
what actually is going to enable the
ability for cloudformation to either be
updated modified removing a resource
adding resource those types of actions
and then in the back end that's actually
what your
application is going to be doing so this
is where you have your root cloud
formation stack
and you know you'd have all of these
different you know variables and these
different you know roles and that's how
you're actually going to be able to
deploy your root stack for AWS amplify
CLI and then
as you add resources you'll maybe see
under backend API or auth or storage or
other types of resources as well so
that's the amplify folder in a nutshell
and
that's pretty much what we'll do so you
won't really have to worry about doing
anything in this we're using the CLI and
it will be programmatically adding or
updating or changing what's in this
folder but we won't have to really worry
any very much about that one thing that
will be of important to note is that
when we have SRC we have this AWS
exports.js file and that's going to be
how AWS
sees our resources so this file is just
a Json object of key value pairs between
a service identifier and what that
service is so when you call an API
endpoint you need to know what the
endpoint you know ID is for auth what's
the auth default mode those types of
things
so when we have our AWS exports file
we'll be able to then call that from the
root of our application and then we'll
be able to access amplify it and then
you know appsync and Cognito and your
storage and the databases and all these
other types of calls to the AWS services
so why don't we do that right now so
we're going to add basically a few lines
of code and we're also going to install
some packages
so when we are working with our
next app
so when we want to use JavaScript so
they have different libraries and they
also have a getting started here so
under next.js
if we go to prerequisite these are the
steps that we have already taken
and we've already done if I configure
set up this so
this is when you set up you know next
application which is what we have
already done we've already initialized
amplify
and we've already configured all of
these things so we're going to take this
import script so this is going to be
installing the AWS amplify package that
Addis amplify UI react
so we're going to take this we're going
to copy it
I'm going to go back to our Repository
we'll save that
we'll do npm install address amplify
like that
we'll wait for that to install
once the amplify packages are installed
in our application
we're then going to go back to
the app
.tsx files so this lives
under pages
there's this underscore app.tx
TSX
file
and what we're going to be doing is
we're going to be adding a few lines of
code so
under app props
I'm going to add some AWS Imports
so we're going to install or import what
was just installed so the amplify API
off and with SSR context
and then AWS exports which is going to
be this file that lives in the SRC file
so is this was just generated for us
so then we're going to then
configure this and we actually
probably don't need
these elements so we can just delete
those and then we're going to be able to
configure amplify
to then serve the whole application so
this is really great because we'll be
able to call our services that we add to
the stack and you know have API and call
IAM and all those those good things that
we're going to need for our application
so give this a save
and the app will probably
um reconfigure
we actually check to make sure that it's
not erroring
give this a quick refresh
and there's no errors so that's great
that means that we are
good so far
so now we're going to do is we are going
to work on some of the steps for
building out our Cloud infrastructure
so we've configured this locally now
let's check out what's happening in AWS
so you can go to the amplify service if
you search for amplify in the search bar
I have this as one of my pinned services
but you'll need to go to the amplify
service in the console in the Management
console on the web and then you should
see your
app right here so I'm going to click on
this and it's immediately going to pull
up a bunch of data about our stack which
is really great because when we start
adding hosting we'll be able to
configure the CI CD pipeline here and
then we'll also see the back end
resources that were deployed in our
stack and we can see that this was
deployed a little while ago so there
isn't any resources associated with it
yet other than just the amplify project
that was configured for it and then we
also have some general and some amplify
Studio settings if we want to enable
those we're not going to get into that
right now but we could if we wanted to
so now what we want to do is we want to
add an API to our application so we'll
switch back to
our application and we will start adding
the schema and API and the Lambda
function for that as well
so to add our API
what we're going to do is we're going to
open up
our tab we'll just press clear
or what we can do is since we just
configured our application
we actually have the suggestion of
amplify add API so when you add services
using the amplify framework it's
literally as easy as amplify adds
something so we do amplify add API
and I'm going to but I'm actually going
to clear this so I can make it
a little bit bigger
actually
might be too big
that should be big enough okay so we'll
do amplify add API
and then we're going to choose graphql
and for authorization modes uh we're
gonna actually need to configure certain
aspects of the flow so we're actually
going to enter here
and we want iam
and configure additional auth types uh
we can say yes
so it might be good to also configure an
API key in case we you know end up
needing that if we wanted to do
something in appsync uh there's
different you know options but you could
also you know utilize Cognito as a user
pool also open ID connect if you wanted
to connect to a third-party provider and
then also Lambda if you wanted to do a
Lambda authorizer or Lambda
authenticated
provider so we're just going to click
API key and a description so
um API key
for inspirational quote generator
and we'll just use the default which is
seven for days API key should expire
and that looks about right so we're
going to press continue
and when you are configuring a schema
this is um it'll give you a couple
different options that you can pick from
but I do think that since we're going to
be configuring our own custom schema
anyway it makes sense to just say single
object with Fields but this is also
sometimes helpful if you want to see
other types of configurations but we'll
do single object with this and then you
want to edit your schema now yes but
we'll see that this is already
compiled correctly so it'll already Auto
open up into
our window here in vs code
so this is great and right away we
already see that we can configure some
scalar types and then we'll be able to
add
scalar types to our scalar values which
is right here and then we'll be ready to
rock so first of all we can just cancel
out this input amplify because we don't
need it this is configuring an auth rule
of global access for everything so we
want to turn that off and make sure that
if we go into production that this isn't
on and I do also just want to unpack
what the iam
was when we
have I am so something that is going to
be important is for us to add
authentication so when we are using IAM
enabling public access to our API
endpoint and we're going to need to
allow uh basically access to use
this API because we're going to give it
an auth directive so we're going to
configure some schema and then we'll add
the auth directives on top of that
so when we go to the backend folder
and then in schema
we are going to configure a couple of
things
so the first thing that we're going to
create is a query so we're going to
actually delete all of this and we're
going to start from the top so there's a
few things that we need so we need a
query we need a way to
speak to Lambda
we need
some sort of public data
and for this query we're going to need a
Lambda function so we know that we need
these elements
in our
database so what are we going to do so
we're going to do type query
we're then going to give this
basically a name so we're going to say
generate
a quote
and then that's going to have an input
of AWS Json
and the input is a string type
and we're going to have an auth
directive with rules
and this is going to allow
Public Access with a provider of IEM
and then
that's it for the auth directives and
then we're going to call a Lambda
function so its name is going to be
inspo
quote
in Spoke quote
Lambda
and then we're going to attach
the
Cloud Branch name to that
so that we're going to be able to append
Dev so it's going to be inspo quote
Lambda hyphen Dev and then that's going
to allow us to work from many different
Cloud backends as we
continue moving along
and if you ever wanted to have you know
like a test Cloud environment or a
production Cloud environment this
function would still be able to be
called but through those different
branches so it's a really great way to
allow
accessibility across your code base and
also call functions you know at
different stages of your Cloud build the
next thing that we're going to configure
is
the public data so we need a public data
object to be able to see how many quotes
are being generated every time that you
know someone runs a quote we want to be
able to track how many quotes were
generated for the entire application
so I'm going to say type quote
app test
we're going to do at modal and this is
going to configure a dynamodb table for
this
type and then we do off
we'll say rules and we'll give it some
auth rules
we're going to say that we're going to
allow Public Access
with a provider of IM with the
operations to read without anything else
so we just want people to be able to
read
this value the value of this database
point but we don't want them to be able
to you know update or delete
or create new objects we're just going
to create one ourselves so this is going
to have an ID ID and this is going to be
the
partition key slash primary key
we do query name
that's going to be a string
and
we're going to have quotes generated and
that's going to be an integer
we're then going to have a created at
string
and also an updated at
string and the bang Operator just means
that it's a mandatory field and
something that we're going to do is on
this query name we're going to enable a
global secondary index or GSI and what
that means is that usually when you have
a database you could just find the
identifier of
that item in the database and then you'd
be able to pull that but one of the
really great benefits of dynamodb with
nosql is that we're able to configure
secondary indexes to query our data more
effectively so if you wanted to query by
a unique name in another field such as
quotes generated or query name you'd be
able to configure that so what we'll do
is we'll say index
we'll then say name
and we're going to give it
quote
query name
and then
query field
quote query name
so this will allow us to find
this object based upon just
querying for
quote query name
so that's great
and can actually just remove
core app and we'll just say core app
data
cool
and
we'll just name that to be consistent
so that should be pretty good in terms
of this now something that we know we're
going to need is auth rules so we're
going to temporarily
just hide that and then we're also
temporarily going to hide this because
we have not set up any sort of
authentication yet
so we're going to save this
now what we're going to do is we're
going to do amplify
add off
so this is how we're going to configure
authentication for
our application so with the default
configuration we'll press enter
so as we are setting this up we are
going to select a username for how users
will sign in
and you want to configure advanced
settings we're going to say yes
so the only required
option that
we want to really focus on just right
now is for email you could configure
more options if you wanted to but we're
not going to focus on that and we're
going to
not worry about any of these right now
but what we will do is we'll do amplify
update off
and then we're going to walk through all
the auth configurations
and how do you want users to sign up uh
we want to use user sign up signing
connected with IAM controls
there's really only you know two options
so this is the one that we're going to
select and this is the major one that we
want to focus on do you want to allow
unauthenticated logins provide scope
information so you can control via AWS
Im so this is very very important and
this is actually referenced in the
documentation so
I will pull that up in one second
so
in the Authentication
modules I'm going to focus on this so
this is under the authorization modes
for a graphql API with appsync so
when we are using AWS IEM to access a
public API or the access public endpoint
we need to make sure that
unauthenticated logins are enabled and
this is where we're doing that update
auth command to then walk through all
the auth configurations so this is
really important because this allows IAM
to then do a handshake with the API and
do basically public authentication if
required so that's a really important
aspect of the authentication
configuration that we need so we're
going to say yes for that
and you do want to enable third-party
authentication providers in your
identity pool we can say no because
we're not going to configure anything
like Google or you know sign in with
Facebook or those other things and you
want to add a user pool group uh we can
say no to this
and do you need an admin queries API you
can say no
multi-factor authentication we can say
that that's off but this is a great
option if you wanted to enable this for
users in your application
and user based forget my password
um yeah we can just keep that as enabled
as the default and then the email
verification subject
we will just keep that basically as the
default so enter enter and then we'll do
enter
and then default is for 30 days and you
want to specify user attributes because
this the default is no
and you want to enable any of the
following capabilities I will just press
enter and you know what to use and oauth
flow we could say notes we're not using
anything with
oauth and you want to configure Lambda
triggers for cognito
say no
so now if we do amplify
status
this is a great feature so we can see
all the aspects of
our cloud formation
stack and waiting so these are create
option operations for a new API and a
new authentication with Cognito setup
so this is great now what's left is
creating this amplify
add function to then create the Lambda
function
and that is how we're going to be
running the function to generate a quote
so this is how this is going to happen
serverlessly
now to add this Lambda function that we
are going to be calling in our query
we can easily add a Lambda function to
our project with amplify add function
and we are going to configure Lambda
function you can also deploy Lambda
layers but we're just going to deploy a
Lambda function here
and we're going to give it a name so
we're going to call it inspo quote
Lambda
and this is going to be a node.js
environment but you could also configure
it with net go Java or python
and we can configure a whole bunch of
different options such as appsync
graphical API we can do crowd function
for Dynamo we could just have a graphql
Lambda authorizer Lambda Trigger or
serverless Express function
that's also configured through API
Gateway but we are just going to use the
hello world template
and do you want to configure advanced
settings we are going to just say no for
now
and you want to edit the local Lambda
function now we'll say yes
and then we'll press enter
all right
so now if we open up our stack
do amplify status of what we are going
to be pushing to the cloud
so right now we have an API we have auth
and we have function so what we want to
be able to do is run these to the cloud
and then we can start to configure some
of the fancy stuff so right now
we're going to be able to create a
integration between our API and our
Lambda function and then we're what
we're going to do is we're going to then
create a relationship between that
Lambda function and the dynamodu table
that gets created because every time
that this function runs successfully we
want to configure this quote app data a
specific object in this data table we're
going to want to increment the quote
generated by plus one so that's where
we're going to configure resource access
so that Lambda can speak to this
dynamodb table but these resources need
to be created and then live in AWS
before we can start dynamically calling
these programmatically so what we're
going to do is we are going to run
amplify
push
and that is what is going to take these
create operations and then push this
right to the cloud so it's going to ask
are you sure you want to continue we're
going to say yes to deploy to our
current environment Dev
and you want to generate code for your
newly created graphical API we're going
to say yes
and what we want to do is we are going
to choose typescript
we're going to enter the file name
pattern which we can just use as the
default
and then you want to generate all
possible graph cooperations queries
mutation subscriptions this is probably
the single best feature of appsync like
hands down once you see this you are
never going to want to configure your
graphical schemas manually ever again I
guarantee you so get ready for that so
we're going to say yes
and maximum statement death uh we don't
really have to worry about that because
our data isn't deeply nested so we can
just say to for now
and enter the file name for the
generated code that's just going to be
under the source folder api.ts and
that's fine so let's just press enter
and now it is going to start deploying
all these resources to the cloud using
our cloud formation
stack that we have generated so you'll
see that there is a update in progress
around the Lambda which is our function
there is going to be the auth
resource that we created and it's going
to be deploying again that API that auth
and that function so those are sort of
those three different resources that we
have configured for
our
AWS application
so we'll wait for these to create and
I'll pick up the recording When the
stack is finished creating these
resources and updating to AWS
so as soon as the cloud formation stack
completes you'll see this
check mark and then it'll say code
successfully was generated and saved to
file SRC api.ts so if we open this up
we'll see that we now have this API file
with
data that maps to our graphql schema so
that's great and we'll also see this
graphql endpoint and also this API key
so this is this endpoint that we'll be
able to use and then this would be an
API key that's generated by AWS for us
to use
our API and we'll also see that this
graphql Transformer was generated and to
actually show you one of the best
aspects of using graphql
with appsync is that in the source
folder you'll see that there is now this
graphql
folder directory and then we'll see that
there's these different TS files so we
go to mutations and what's awesome is
that this was all auto-generated by
appsync so we have now this quote app
data
mutation
we have this update quote app data
and all of these are scoped to the
conditions that we set up in our API so
the same thing with query so now we have
this generate a quote we have this list
quote app data
we have quotes query name which was that
Global secondary index that we
configured
and
you have all this data which is really
great and then also for subscriptions if
we wanted to have websockets we could
have oncreate quote app data as a
subscription so that's where all of
these different elements were created
and this is all by appsync and on the
clouds that will be able to actually
have these queries and mutations and
subscriptions configurable in our
front-end application without needing to
worry about any sort of back end
um configurations it's all done for us
which is really really great
so now what we're going to do is we are
going to
open up our schema
and we're going to now run
amplify status
so this is going to give us perspective
on
what resources are currently generated
in the cloud for us
so when we run amplify status this gives
us a current understanding of the stack
and what is deployed and what is local
and in changing so we have our API we
have our author we have our function and
there's no current changes right now and
that makes sense because we just
committed this to AWS and pushed this to
our AWS account
so now in our
schema we have this query that's
attached to this function we have an
auth directive we have auth directive
and now we want to do is we want to
add these auth directives back into our
schema we commented them out earlier now
we're going to add them so now that we
have
basically our authentication system set
up and we know this because we have auth
a part of this
we can now add auth directives to our
API so that we can
prevent certain users from accessing or
running certain features and what we
want to be able to do is for example
allow public access to read
data that we'll create we'll create an
object in here and then we'll want users
to be able to find this specific object
and then query from it and same thing
with this query to generate a quote we
want to be able to allow users to
publicly
run this Lambda function but using the
IAM as a provider so what we're going to
do is we're going to
uncomment those changes which we've done
we're then going to do amplify push
and then we're going to say continue
we're going to say yes and we'll see
here that this is an update to our API
but it's not updating anything else it's
just updating this API and that's really
great about the
amplify framework is that and we'll just
say yes to all of these because we're
going to update our schema so what's
really great about amplify working with
cloud formation is that you're only
going to update the resources in the
stack that need to be updated everything
else will stay the same and it's
managing all of this for you so that you
don't have to worry about you know did I
need to update this or do I need to
configure this it's all going to be
doing this for you in the cloud so I'm
going to pause the recording and then
I'll resume it when the stack finishes
updating
now that our graphql operations have
successfully generated been saved to the
source graphical folder and we've also
had the of our api.ts file updated we
can actually now check this out and see
if it did that
so for queries
we have some more
information here
and
this is all going to show that these
were updated
so there and then for mutations uh
those files were updated there and those
were generated uh recently as well so
now that we have these configured
something that we're going to want to do
is now check out our
amplify project so when we go back to
the Management console and we do a
refresh here
now we see that we have API we have
authentication we have functions so
before we didn't have any of these
resources created and now we have three
of them which is great so if we click on
API
let me scroll down
we now see that we have some data
sources associated with our
inspirational quotes Dev API endpoint
with graphql so what we're going to be
creating is this public data object in
nosql that we're then going to query
from the front end and every time that a
quote is generated we're going to be
incrementing that value by plus one but
it's not going to be us it's going to be
Lambda that's doing that so we're going
to go to our quote app data table
and this is going to dynamically find
this table in our
amplify
so it's amplify project and then
dynamodb resource and then when we
explore table items we're then going to
be able to open this up we're then going
to create an item
and what we're then going to do is we're
going to start configuring
our nosql
object and there's two options when
writing items to dynamodb from the
Management console you can put it with
basically key value pairs as a form or
you can write it as Json personally I
think that writing the form is easier so
let's use this and then I'll show you
how this Json object actually looks like
when it's finished
so when we want to have our ID so we
have the ID as part of the partition key
so this is how we're initially able to
query objects in a nosql dynamodb table
so given this ID would be able to find
it so I generated this string now what
we're going to do is we'll go back to
our schema here
so we see here that when we have quote
app data so this is going to be the same
as quote app data there
with series of characters and then the
dev Branch so we have a query name we
have a quotes generated we have a
created at and we have an updated ad so
those are going to be the variables that
we can have associated with this
dynamodb object so this is the same as
our schema so we're going to want to
have that the same so you could just
copy this
go back here
we're going to do a string
do query name
now we're just going to match this so
this is an integer
a real number so quotes generated we'll
go back here
we're going to do number
quotes generated
and then created at and updated at are
going to both Be Strings so we create
another string here created that and
one more string and that's going to be
updated at
sweet
so under a query name
we're going to call this live
so paste in live
the courts generated that value is set
at zero
and that's because we're going to be
starting from zero and then created at
and updated at so those are going to be
AWS date timestamp and if you don't
already know how to do this I will help
you write a script for that so that we
can generate it
all right so to make a script that can
get us created at and updated at I think
this will be a good utility for you to
have so if you ever need to generate uh
updated out or created at timestamps
you'll be able to then configure a
script to then run that so anytime that
you ever you know need to get those
types of values you'd be able to have a
script that generates it yourself so
we're going to open up another code
sandbox
Cloud environment
this is specifically node.js same as we
did before but this is a different one
and we're going to call this AWS
date time stamp
generator
cool
so
now that we have this
we're going to remove this
save that and we're going to open up a
terminal here we're going to clear this
out
and something we're going to do is we're
going to install
moment so moment is a package for
working with timestamps and time
signatures so once we've added that with
npm install we'll see that it's now part
of our
dependencies here
now when we run this we're going to
import
moment so we'll do const moment equals
require
moment
next we will create a variable for our
AWS date timestamp so we'll do const AWS
date
time equals moment so we'll use that
moment
Library we're going to do UTC
because we want universal time and then
we're going to do format and this is
where we're able to use that moment
library to create the date and the exact
format format that we want so we'll do y
y y for year
and we'll do months months then we'll do
day day
tea for time and then we do our hour
minute minute
second second
and then millisecond
and then Z
in bracket
and then close out that string
and then we'll print out our
AWS date time stamp right there
and we will try to we'll save this and
then we will run it
so run this
cool so we're able to get our value
right here so this is where we'd be able
to plug that in
to our Dynamo and you can also see here
if we if we run this again
the number is getting bigger each time
so it's counting upwards so that's how
we know that it's working so you can use
this utility for
and I'll just make this a little bit
bigger so you can see the full script so
you can use this utility
any time that you want to get an AWS
date time stamp and yeah use this for
any project that you need so this will
be a good script to just have you know
in code sandbox and you can run this you
know whenever you need to get this type
of string so we'll go back here we'll
add this value here and we'll add this
value here
now that we have all the values a part
of our item we can go and create this
item
and now it is an item that lives in our
database and
if we open up this structure so to give
you a little bit of perspective about
what we just created so this is what a
dynamodb Json object will look like so
it is a little bit counter-intuitive in
terms of how you might think about the
structure
happening so instead of these values
being directly related to the the scalar
type or the item that's associated with
the API it'll basically be its own
object and then it will be S for string
or n for number and these will be mainly
the types of types that you'll be
configuring so just look out for you
know strings or numbers those are
usually the the two main ones that we'll
be working with so
those are the values so we had the ID
which was our unique value we had the
string that we created with the node.js
script we have this query name which is
live which where we configured a global
secondary index for we have zero for the
quotes generated and then we have again
this timestamp that we generated from
the script so this looks great and now
we have an item in our database that we
can work from
so if we wanted to go back to our front
end that we have here so instead of just
being hard-coded with zero we're going
to want to hydrate this value with a
query from our API endpoint so let's go
back to our code and let's work on a way
to generate a function that can call
that value in Dynamo now that we've
created it so now that we've written
quite a bit of code this is a good time
for us to get into the habit of pushing
all of these changes that we've made to
our GitHub repository
so you'll see here that we have quite a
lot of files that have been created
modified
updated
and now we're going to
say that we add API
plus Lambda Plus auth
and we'll also review if we added any
front-end changes but mainly we've been
doing
lots of
Cloud backend things so we're just at we
added API we added Lambda we added off
and we added a graphql so that's the
queries mutations and subscriptions and
the api.ts file so this should be all
good so we'll Commit This to Main
with GitHub desktop we'll push to origin
and this is then good because now we
know that we have our code as a backup
in case we ever need to revert back to
anything that we did
so now what we want to do is we want to
go to our index.ts file
and I'm actually going to just
comment this out just so that we can get
rid of
that typescript error
so now we want to do is we want to
change this number of quotes to be
receiving data from
our dynamodb table
so what we're going to do is we are
going to first of all check out and I
can actually
move this here so that this is full
screen so what we're doing is this is
always going to be a number
we want to be able to dynamically change
the set number of quotes value to what
is rendered out from dynamodb so we're
going to use appsync and query our
public data object that we just created
and then use that data to then set the
number of quotes so that when we call
this value it's going to be the number
that's coming from AWS instead of this
locally stored value in state right off
the bat since we are going to be using
typescript in our project which we are
we are going to start to think about our
data types with interfaces so an
interface is just a way where we can
explain throughout our code base what
are the different data types that might
be in an object so when we're getting
data from dynamodb we might need to
Define what the ID would be or the
quotes generated which would be a number
for example so we need to just Define
those so that typescript won't
be confused as to what we're doing so
we're going to say that we need to
create an interface
for our Dynamo
DB object
and also something we're going to need
to do is we need to create a type guard
for our
fetch function
so we're going to need a type guard to
then check when we query for the data
and Dynamo we're going to need to make
sure that the response is actually the
response that we would be expecting and
in the format that it's expecting so how
we're going to do this is
we're going to first create
this interface for our update quote info
data so we'll do interface
date quote info data
and then we're basically going to take
all of our schema from here
and we're just going to copy that over
with a few exceptions
so we want this we don't want that
Global secondary index because that's a
dynamodb thing
but we are going to need these things
so now what we need is we're going to
turn this into a string
and we're going to add string to almost
all of these except for the quotes
generated
because that's a number
so in here
we'll do number
and then we'll
give that a save and then this is going
to Define that data type for the data
that we're going to fetch from dynamodp
now
I think it is helpful also just to think
about the function that we're going to
write so we're going to just move over
to that for a quick second so we're
going to need a function
function to fetch
the object which is quote generated
cool
so what we're first going to need to do
is
this is going to be an async function so
we're putting that inside of the
functional component
but before the return statement
so we're going to do const
update quote info
equals async
we'll make this an arrow function and
just a good habit of getting into is
using try catches when we
are
running
functions
so a try catch is basically
hey run this code otherwise if there's
an error in this then log that error and
basically console log it or do some
action so what we want to really do is
we're going to say
error getting quote data
and then error
so what we do want to be able to do is
fetch the data out of
dynamodb
so we're going to expect a response so
we'll do const response equals await
we'll do API
do graphql and then we're going to take
that type
that we got from here and then throw
that in there
we'll close out the arrow bracket
we're going to use parentheses
curly bracket and then we're going to
create a way in which we can
API so the API is
module we can get out of the AWS amplify
Library so we can import that
up there and then now it's a part of our
Imports
now if you want to use appsync with
those queries that we generated so we
have this query here so we're going to
be fetching
this quote
query name so this was already generated
by appsync which is awesome so we're
going to be using this query to then get
that data so it's already configured for
us but this is what it looks like so if
we want to do use the api.graphql method
to call appsync data using that query
we'll do query we're going to do quotes
query name which was our Global
secondary index and I see that it's
already Auto populating this so we're
going to press enter
and how this will look at the top is
it's going to say import
query name from graphical queries which
is what the file that we were just in so
that's great now we can do query
for the auth method if you remember from
before when we allowed IAM we're going
to be defining that as the auth mode
use osmode we'll do AWS Instagram plan
there's already methods that it will see
so I will just choose AWS IM
then under variables because this is
what we're going to send into this query
the query name that we want to fetch for
is live
because that's the
item that we created in Dynamo
so that all looks good
and now for our response
we could just do console log response
equals response
just because we want to test if we're
actually able to get this object out of
dynamodb so we can do that just to test
it really quickly and make sure that
we're on the right path and we actually
need to be able to invoke this function
so how are we going to do this we will
use a hook called use effect so use
effect
that's going to be Arrow function and
then we're going to take
that function that we just wrote
we'll put that in there
and then an important aspect of use
effect is and I'll just import this from
react from the top so
we'll import that so now it'll do react
use effect and use state so those two
hooks from the react library from the
framework so this is really important
because use effect is really helpful for
side effects but you need to make sure
that you unsubscribe otherwise it's
going to keep invoking this all the time
so sometimes that can be helpful if you
want to run a certain function after a
certain type of action so let's say that
you know you um every time that you
uh complete a game you want to restart
it well you could listen for that as a
method or an input and then you could
you know clear out the game and then
restart it or something like that so
because we're just writing this we want
this function to run every time that
this page loads so this is the way in
which we do that so that's just a way to
tell
use effect and react in the Dom hey once
we run this function you know when the
page loads don't don't do it again just
unsubscribe
so that's great so we're going to now
give this a save and we're going to open
up our
application backup and we're going to
test to see if this is actually working
so I'm going to give this a quick
refresh
and this is Crete so I see that it's
getting something so let's see if this
is the actual data
so we go down a whole bunch
and this looks exactly like what we have
so we have that ID which was that string
we have the query name which was live we
have the 10 quotes here and updated at
there and let's actually go back to this
object just so that we can
change it so let's say that we change
that to 15. we'll do save
go back
back to our application and we'll give
this another reload
and let's see if we're actually able to
get the different data that we just
changed
go to items this item and that gives 15.
so it seems like we're actually able to
do this and it's working successfully
which is awesome so now we know that
we're able to run a function that is
querying using our Global secondary
index of live to get this data object in
Dynamo and then render that back
in our console so now we're going to
change and basically take this value and
then change it to state so that it'll
overwrite the zero and something
important to note here is when we are
getting this response data so you'll see
that there's this data and then it's dot
you know quotes query name dot items
down there's this zero so it's the first
item in the list of the array and then
you have these data points so the one
that we're going to want is quotes
generated but you see that there's these
different levels to the data structure
so this becomes really important because
we need typescript to understand that
this data has nested data inside of it
and then we're going to be working our
way down into this quotes generated
value and I'm going to show you why
that's actually really important because
let's say that we wanted to just set the
quote number so you know we're going to
use set quotes number and you know we
could theoretically change it to be a
number right we know that it's 15 in
the database
so we could we could do that but that's
not the number it's going to be changing
in the database so let's say that we are
going to take the
response.data.all of these things and
we're going to put that in here so I
already have this data type and we're
going to work on this you know together
but this is the response it's
response.data.query.name.items
take the first item out of that and then
we get quotes generated and that's going
to be the number that is 15 that's
what's in the database right now but
we're going to get this nasty error from
typescript and it's going to say
property data does not exist on type
graphql result with this observable
object and then it basically says that
property data does not exist on type
observable with the object so that's not
great and typescript is going to get
upset and that's going to be no good so
what we really need to do is understand
how are we getting the data out of
response and then mapping all of these
down so this is where that type guard
that we worked on before that's where
that comes in
so we're just going to comment that out
for a quick second so where we're going
to actually start plugging away on this
is we want to write a type card which is
really a function that checks against
types and the expected value that you
would be expecting so we're going to say
function and then we're going to say is
graphql result
for
quote
for quotes
query name
I'm just going to capitalize this
between him
we know that we're going to get a
response that response is going to be
any for this and that response
is graphql
result and we can get graph quill result
from at AWS amplify
dot API
which we can import here
so we'll import that and then it goes
from AWS amplify API graphql
so now what we want to do is
we're going to make a carrot bracket
I'm going to go down
and then we're going to Define this type
that we want so we're going to do quote
query name
and I'm actually I'm going to just
uncapitalize that just so that it can
match up with
this data type that we have from before
so under this we're going to get some
items
but we're really just going to get one
item but it would be an array anyway and
I'm going to do update quote info data
create that and then we'll do
semicolon
and then we're gonna give this a closed
out
carrot and then we're going to be
returning
a response
dot data
and we're also going to return our
response dot data dot quotes query
name which is
that query there
and we're also going to be potentially
getting which is really what we're going
to be doing is a response dot data dot
quotes
query name dot items
so these are the different outputs that
we could get when we are trying to check
along that is graphql result for quotes
query name Global secretary index
so where this comes into play is we now
can check against all of these different
responses
related to
our data query
so we can comment this out because we
already know that we're getting that
data
so now we're going to create
type cards
so if
not is graphical result for query name
given a response
will then throw new error
and then we'll say
unexpected
response from API Dot graphql
next up we'll do if not
response.data
we're then going to throw a new error
that will say response data is undefined
[Applause]
next up now we're actually going to get
the received number of quotes about
variable and then we're going to use
that to set the number of quotes so
instead of it being zero it'll now be
changed to the value of the database so
we'll do const received number of quotes
equals response dot data dot quotes
query name dot items
get the first item in the array
and do quotes generated as that value
and you can already see that there's
autocomplete going on to it it knows
this value and again remember when we
did the the interface it knows that this
is a number so this is perfect because
now when we try to set
number of quotes
will be able to take this value and put
that to this number and we get no errors
and that's because this knows that it's
a number this is set to set State action
to a number and number of quotes is a
number and we set it to zero so now we
can set it to be a different number so
before we do save so this is zero from
before and I'm just going to zoom in
here so this is zero
but now when we save it
this number now changed to be 15 super
quickly right so now let's say that we
want to change this and also a cool
aspect of dynamodb is we can edit this
and we can save it really quickly so
we'll do save
foreign
we'll just do save and then space and
now 17's there we could do this even one
more time we could do
40.
we'll just you know undo that space
we'll save it
open up this and now this is 40. so this
is great so now we know that we're
actually able to get real-time data
out of our object and of course we can
double check this with items go to that
item we'll do refresh
and can always uncomment out console log
response
and check this out so that's 40. so now
we know that this is actually fetching
the data dynamically from our database
using our graphql API that we set up
using appsync so this is super great so
now we know that we're actually able to
fetch and get Dynamic data from our from
our application and we can always
refresh this
and we're still going to get that and
you'll actually see that it'll go from 0
to 40 and that's the hydration happening
where we take our you know State and
then we fill it with data that we get
from our API from our fetch function so
this is awesome so now we know that this
is working and this is great so we
already got the dynamodb part down now
we're going to work on the Lambda
component to get every time that we
press make a quote it's then going to
use our API it's then going to fire off
Lambda Lambda is going to generate that
quote string for us and then we're going
to pass that back to the front end so we
can actually see our quotes so that's
going to come up next for something that
we probably want to do since we don't
have 40 quotes here we can always just
set this back to zero give that a save
and now we'll refresh and now it's back
to zero but it's the actual
data from our database not just Zero
from you state locally
so we did it so great job so now we're
going to move on to the Lambda component
of our application
since we just did a lot of great stuff
we are going to want to commit this to
GitHub so we can
label this
commit
query to Dynamo
for public quotes data works
so we'll commit to Main
and we'll give that a push
all right so now we have that saved
which is great so now what we're going
to do is we are going to work on
the functionality where when you click a
button click this button it's going to
actually do something because
right now we want to add some
functionality to this button and then
actually have it do something in our
application so for the Lambda component
there's going to be two separate parts
there's the front end component and then
there is the actual function
calling and then receiving so we're
going to work on the front end first and
then we'll um we'll work on the function
as well
right after that so what we're going to
do is we're going to find where our
background is which is right here and
then the code generator modal pop-up is
going to be here so this is where we're
going to be actually working on
the generator modal here so we can
uncomment this out
foreign
and this is going to live right on top
of the quotes generator container so
there's going to be a number of
different values that we're going to
pass into
this but we don't really have to worry
about those just yet but we'll just kind
of mock them out for now
so we're just gonna
basically give this I'm just going to
copy these into it and then we'll
comment them out and then add them later
so there's going to be an open and a
closed function so we're going to call
that through clicking outside of this
button you know obviously it'll Auto
open when we open it but then we'll be
able to close it and these will be
operating through functions then there's
going to be a processing quote there's
going to be a set processing quote value
and then there's going to be a quote
received value and then a set quote
received value so these are going to be
the different inputs that we pass into
our function we're just going to comment
this out for now because we're just
going to work on the component
so
this is going to live
in our quote generator so we're going to
find
code generator we're going to call this
and we already set up this folder from
before create a new file I'm going to
call this index.tsx
and then this is where we're going to
actually start creating our code
generator component so if you want to
just quickly spin up a react functional
component you could do rafce
and that's going to be our react Arrow
functional export component here
and then we'll do quote generator
cool and if you're wondering how I did
that that is an extension that is you
can just get extensions from the
extension store and then that'll be for
react Snippets so it's one of the most
popular extensions and it just saves you
a lot of time from the guesswork of
having to you know configure
these different you know like Imports
and then getting the rec you know Arrow
function and everything it just spins it
up really quickly and it makes it really
easy to use
to build out this component we are going
to first remove that placeholder and
then we're going to do modal
and we're going to import this from
Material UI so this is that component
that we showed earlier which is
let me show you guys motor component so
that's when you click a button and then
there's a pop-up and it you know might
blur out other things that are in the
background around it that's what this
modal is doing to get the modal we need
to add in a number of different values
as inputs for the modal we are going to
have quite a number of these inputs so I
will take these and then I'll paste them
below and then we'll go through each one
so
given an ID so we're just going to give
this an easy to recognize name which is
quote generator modal there's an aria
labeled by and a described by so this is
just going to be that spring modal title
encryption so we could give this a name
so just call this quote generator
modal
and then description
say
opens
and closes
quote generator
now and this will also just help with
readability in the application
now in terms of open we're going to be
passing in a value which will be a
Boolean and then on close will be a
function and then close after transition
is a value which you'll you'll see in
action there backdrop is just some
styling related to how this works and
then we also have a backdrop props
timeout
so now what we need to do is we are
going to be passing in some data here so
we're definitely going to be getting
open and we're going to be passing in
close and these are going to be
functions that we're going to pass down
from
this
so where we do this is that we'll do
open and close
and now we need to get these there and
also this is not imported yet so we'll
just backspace we'll rewrite l
and this actually might not be importing
so we'll create a another import at the
top we'll say import
and it seems like this is already going
to be
passing that and this might not
like that so what we can do is we can
just say quotes generator
and that should work
and then
if we undo that
then
should work
is that something that we can do here is
like that and then we'll just rewrite
that
so that it will then recognize that
component so that's a way that we can
fix that
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to need to work on these inputs
here so the open and the close are going
to be two values that we passed down
from the parent component to this
child's component so here
under open generator
so that's going to be
a Boolean value that we set with u state
so we're going to use U State again here
we'll go to the top
and then we're going to say const
open generator and this is already
prompting us to write that so open
generator and then set open generator
we're going to set it to be
false from the start but when we run a
function this we're going to use set
open generator and then that's going to
make it true
so
under open generator now that value is
fine now for our close function we're
going to want to make this as a function
at the top
so we can put this after our type card
from before
so we'll create a function called const
handle close generator
write a function and then we'll do we'll
take this from the top
we can actually put this inside of our
function here
I'll put that there so we'll do um
function for quote
generator modal
because we'll have a few functions here
so handle closed generator we're going
to set number of or sorry not for this
one
we're going to be importing
set open generator
and then
we're going to set that to be false
because we're going to be closing that
and then we'll add some other things as
well but we will work on those later
so now what we want is we're going to go
back to that button that we had before
and remember when we had on click and we
made it as an all we're going to make
our own function to actually open up
this modal and that's going to be called
handle
open generator
now when we take this
we're then going to make this a function
so
this is inside of our functional
component here we'll put this
underneath that so then we're going to
do const handle open generator
async and then we're going to pass in an
event
which will be a react
synthetic event
which is the type
so typescript will be able to recognize
that and then we're going to do e dot
prevent
default so this is a way that you can
run a function without reloading the
page and that becomes very important
because when you need to pass in data
into something you don't want to be
reloading the page because you want to
be able to manage the state
um of the dominant and not be updating
it or refreshing it you want it to be
processing
a function or a script so we're going to
use that and then we're going to do set
open generator
to be true so this is where every time
that we open up
or we press that button which is going
to be here
we then want to make
basically this set open generator to be
true
and we're going to be doing a bunch of
other elements in this later but we'll
worry about that at a later point so now
when we open
and close
typescript is going to complain and it's
going to say hey I see that you passed
these down but I don't understand what
the interface is that we're going to be
using here so this is where we're going
to use typescript and we're going to
define a type so that or an interface so
that typescript will understand exactly
what open and close are supposed to do
in our application to get rid of these
errors we're going to be creating an
interface so that typescript will
understand the types of values that
we're going to be or the variables and
those values we're going to be passing
into it so we're going to create a
interface and we're going to call it
quote
moral props
and this is going to be a value that
we're going to put inside of this
so this is going to help to Define open
and close inside of that scope
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go down we're going to do interface
we're going to copy this
and then we're going to make this into
an object so it seems like it's already
understanding that these are going to be
certain values so Boolean and close
so now that's how we get rid of those
errors and this is because we need to
let typescript understand what this
modal and the values that are going to
be passed into it
actually are going to be so this is a
Boolean which is true or false and then
close is a function
so that's great so now what we're going
to do and we're going to pass in
as I'm sure you've guessed it a whole
bunch of other data later but these are
just the two ones that we want to be
checking for right now
we could do of course the other stuff
later
so now we're going to do is we are going
to
work on this backdrop element
so backdrop is imported from Material UI
so we're going to be
just reorganizing a little bit of our
project here
so we're gonna say material UI Imports
so the modal is imported from there
and then we're also going to import
backdrop
so
if we just backspace we can find that
backdrop as this one so we'll import
that so modal and backdrop will all be
imported
from material
and now mortal is going to say that
there is something that is missing so
what we need to do is we need to pass in
some other values into
the modal since we need to have
something inside of it for a to a render
so we're going to pass in this fade
effect or styling which I really like
to give it a little bit more of a classy
element to it and for fade
we'll be able to import that also for
material UI
so that'll also be imported from the mey
material library and then we need to
have something inside of this because
these are still effects we need to have
some text in there
so what we could do is we could just say
each one
hello world
and then
our core generator is just going to have
some text
this is going to and like that and let
us test to see if this actually can
function
so if we click on this
check that out so now we can open this
and there's this text here we see the
hello world when it's there and anytime
that we click outside of this modal it's
um that's how we'll be able to close it
out or if you click on this and then you
press Escape that's also how you'll be
able to to close out of it so we're
getting closer obviously we need to add
some Styles in here but this is the
basic functionality if you click this
then it's going to be rendering it's
going to be processing the generation of
the quote and then it'll pass that back
and then if we you know click out of
that div then we'd be able to close out
of the modal so this is some great
progress before to round out the rest of
these Imports
to our child's component from this
parent component let's add those right
now so we go up to the top under our
function
and we're going to add a number of
different
processing quote generation statuses
so new const
and then we're going to create a
variable to check for the processing
quote status so processing quote
and then suppressor quote and then
we also have a set processing quote and
then that's going to be set
automatically to false
and then we're going to have another
variable
called const quote received and this is
actually going to be the value that
we get back from our Lambda function so
set quote received
and then this is going to be use date
but instead of it being a value like a
Boolean value it's going to be set to
null because we're going to fill it with
data when we get that back but it's
going to be set to nothing when we start
so this is going to be a string and this
is going to be that base 64 encoded
string that I keep talking about but
you're actually going to see what it
looks like in a little bit but this is
where we're going to be filling this
value with that string
for the image
so
let's take this and we're going to pass
this down
and then these are going to be the other
ones so quote received and then set
quote received
but of course
typescript is going to complain it's
going to say hey you don't have this
value so we're going to be passing these
four values into our type in our
interface in the child component so this
is that quote generator file
and under open close we then need to
pass in those other values to do that we
are going to be putting those in as
inputs so we can actually Define the in
the interface that might be a little bit
easier just to explain so we added those
in here so those are our four more
inputs
processing quote
we are going to Define that as a Boolean
then for set processing quote
is actually going to be a specific type
of react dispatch
so this is that type so it's react
dispatch
and then react set State action to a
Boolean so it's Boolean but this is the
type for that
and then for quote received
this is going to be a string or it's
going to be no
and then it's going to be the same
basically the same type of react
dispatch react set State action except
it's going to model State string and
null
so that's what that will look like and
then
we're going to pass those into
here
so it might be helpful also to start
writing these down and then just passing
them in like that
just in case that's a little bit easier
to read
then we pass this
and then we do this one and add that one
as an input and then set quote received
and that is an input
so that's going to be great so this is
going to allow us to then pass down that
data as props into our child's component
so we can then use it when we're trying
to render out the different states of
the quote being generated
so now we're going to do is we're going
to get rid of that hello world because
we know that this is working
and then we're going to do
another component which we will call
quote generator modal
container
and material UI has this styling where
you can pass in custom styles
so I'll show you how to do that in one
moment
and then inside of this we're going to
do quote generator modal inner container
so this is where we're going to be
including some Styles but
specifically for the style that we're
going to import here
we can just Define
a value
outside of our component
which we could
report up here
we just see const style and then this is
where if you follow the
material UI style guide you'd be able to
then pass in you know your own style as
you like
but that'll be an import into that and
then modal container and then inner
container
we're going to need to create separate
styled components so what we will do is
we will open up
quote generator this and then we'll
press Ctrl B and that will just close
that out and then we're going to be
making our quote generator elements
Stout component in this library in this
uh this file so again if you remember
we'll do exsc
we'll then do quote generator modal
container
and this is not going to be styled div
it's going to be a
component from Material UI called box
so we're going to do styled box
and then we can import that from
Material UI
so it will look like this
and then
we're going to pass in a whole bunch of
styles into
this component so I'll show you what
those are in one moment
so we're going to give it a position of
absolute with a top 50 left 50 transform
translate minus 50 minus 50 so that's
going to Center this box this style of
the Box inside of
the screen
it's going to have a 70 view width and a
height of 70 view height and that's
going to make sure that it spans
around
the screen so as it gets smaller or as
it gets larger this will be expanding
to match what that pop-up is that's in
the um the main screen and then we give
it a box Shadow just for some styling
and then we're giving it a background
we're giving it a box Shadow we're doing
some backdrop filtering and sort of
giving it that glossomorphic effect that
we were talking about from earlier and
then also giving it a border
similar to what we had before so that's
great
so now we're going to need to also
create
the inner container so
as I'm sure you guessed it we're gonna
do exsc we're going to pass that in
and then this is going to be
another set of styles
so this is going to be style.div
and we have our
top 50 left 50 transfer translate minus
50 minus 50 and then a position relative
so there's going to be this inner
container that's going to be inside of
our modal container so this overall
this overall element this overall
component is going to be centered inside
of the screen and then we're going to
have inside of this our own series of
styles so this is just how you can
create divs within divs and then Center
those divs within other Center divs and
that just will help with organization of
your of your application
so now we can do is we can rewrite the N
here we can then import this from quote
generator elements
and then that will import that at the
top we'll rewrite the last letter here
and then that will import that as well
so then these get imported from quotient
or elements which makes sense so we'll
give this a save we'll give this a save
and then we can see if this is going to
start generating some styles so it looks
looks like it is so this is really great
so we can click inside of this div but
as soon as we click outside of it then
it'll disappear
so that's not that's not bad right and
then we can press Escape as well and
then that will also close it out so
seems like it's working pretty well so
now we're going to do is we are going to
then start adding some of these elements
into
our page now that our modal is working
we need to create two different states
so state number one
would be
you are processing
request of quote
and
quote state is empty
so this is going to basically say hey
we're trying to fetch this data from the
cloud right now and there's nothing you
know in there just yet locally
state number two
is going to be
quote received
so that means that we have a quote
passed back so quote state
you can actually say
so in order to make sure that we can
actually process these states correctly
and then have our front end do the
correct actions what we're going to do
is we're going to pass down those
properties that we're importing from
here so these where we're processing the
quote or the quote is received we're
going to use those to dynamically switch
out how the front end operates so what
we're going to do is we're going to
start creating
some elements so we're going to do
processing quote
so if that is true
meaning we are trying to fetch the quote
from Lambda
and the quote received
is null meaning there is nothing there
it's empty
then
we're going to render this specific set
of front-end code and this is a Nifty
operator for working in react where you
can really just Define certain elements
here and then you just say and and then
you don't need to do like if this else
something it's just if this is true this
is going to be the code so you don't
have to have like
it wouldn't be like this would be like
an else else like you don't have to do
something like that
um you can just write your code in
not have to worry about the the other
types of conditions so something we're
going to do is we're going to create a
component for a circular progress meter
which we'll call
modal
circular progress
and that is going to be given some data
so it's going to be given a size
we're going to call that eight REM
and REM is just a way to size certain
divs and elements and then we're going
to give this
a 2.5 thickness
and then we're going to also have a
title so we're gonna have quote
generator title
and this is going to say creating
your quote
and this is where that's going to be
that loading pattern so this would sort
of make sense that it's creating your
quote for you and you know we're told to
wait until we finish that up
so we are told otherwise that it's that
it's there
then
um what we're going to do is we are
going to then have a quote generator
subtitle
and we're gonna give this a style of
margin top
20 pixels
and I thought that this was kind of a
little bit funny so what we could do is
if we wanted to have some data such as a
quote so I thought this would be kind of
fun where it's creating your quote and
then you'd have sort of this
inspirational quote as it's waiting I
thought that would be kind of fun so
what we'll have is we'll do wise Dev
quote
and then I'm gonna have a break
and then
we're gonna do span
style equals
font size
26 so we're just going to be changing
the styles
with that span that we talked about
earlier but
we're going to have a quote
and then we're going to say
wise Dev quote author
and then we end the span
yeah Ben's gonna say that it can't find
that because we haven't defined that
variable yet
and that should round out the rest of
this element so now we're going to do is
we're going to Define
these elements so right after the
Imports but before return
to actually just take this and make this
a little bit more tabbed so that it's a
little more organized
so we're gonna do const
because these are constant values
and then I'm going to copy this quote
that I created so I thought this would
be kind of a little bit funny where it's
you say if you can enter a div Anything
is Possible
because I firmly believe that that is
true
and then we author
and then I'm going to pass down the
author of
this so we're just going to take this
so it's going to basically look like
that
it's going to look like this
and then a wise senior software engineer
so that's great
so those are the two variables that
we're going to pass down into here
and then now these are where we need to
create some styled components
and this might be expecting
a value here it's maybe no parentheses
yeah so we can just get rid of that
parentheses because that was just an
extra one and now we just need to worry
about the Styles components so we're
going to go back to our Styles
components from before
and we'll have this open on the side
and then we will of course do exsc
we're going to say modal circular
progress
and this is not going to be a div this
is going to be the material UI I'm going
to make this a little bit bigger so you
can see this is going to be the styled
circular progress and this is an element
out of the material UI
component Library
and then we're going to pass in a number
of different styles into
this component
so we're going to make the color white
we're going to make the stroke line cap
round so that it's not cut it's rounded
out the positions to be relative
and then just to account for the larger
element pushing to the left we're just
going to add this so a margin left of
-55 pixels a left to 50 and a transform
translate of 50 percent
so then
we could have that and then we'll work
on the generator title
so the generator title is going to be
created with exsc
we have the title this is going to be a
div and then we're going to pass in
some Styles here
and we're going to have a font family
here
we're going to have font size and this
might
already be used
so I do wonder if this is going to be
the same as the previous one
and I think that we could just reuse
this one I'm just double checking the
Styles here but I think we can use the
same one so you can actually just
import that
already
and that'll be the same one here
and then subtitle
you can use the same one there
and for modal circular progress we can
just import that component that we just
created
now we'll give our
styled component elements a save and
then we'll give that a save
and believe we could also give this a
save too
so now we've passed down those
components those are properties into the
child's component now let's just remove
these State variables and let's see what
this looks like when we open the modal
and there's you know no variables to
worry about
all right so seems like when we click on
this
will then be getting this loading State
it's going to say creating your quote
and then it's we get that fun
inspirational quote there and
everything's operating pretty great so
as we click on this of course able to
click out of it but then you can also
press escape and then that'll work great
so now we want to do is we want to pass
these values back in
and we're not actually updating this
processing quote so the reason why this
is going to be important is if we save
that and we try to press this button we
don't get anything here so we still get
the pop-up but we don't get anything in
here and that's because
processing quote is still set to be
false and we know this because when we
go back to this other example
to our parent component
we're not actually setting processing
quote state yet so that's why this is
still false
so what we need to do is we need to have
a methodology for how we can
create
a way where when we are fetching our
quote we're going to be able to then
start
changing this value
so we're going to go to our function
that we created with the try catch
for the handle open operation
which is going to be here
and under handle open operation we
already have this value here where we
set this to be true we're going to Now
set processing quote to be true
now we're going to do a try catch
and this is where we're going to be
running our Lambda stuff so run
Lambda
function
and then this is where we're going to be
getting a whole lot of data
otherwise we're going to do catch do
error
console vlog
error generating
quote
log the error
and then we will set processing
quote to be false so this means that
it's
timing out after we finish that out
and something also that we can do is
that in the try catch
we know at the end of it we will need to
set the processing quote to be false
because as we run it we then will need
to
because we make it true we will need to
make it false at the end of it so that
it the the function ends and terminates
and then sets processing quote to be
false so that's a good methodology for
us to go down
so as we process this it should actually
allow us to see it for a quick second
but it might actually be way too fast to
even
see that there's data that's processing
yeah it's going to be too short so when
we are fetching this function for a
while it might be like you know a second
or two but we will actually see
that spinning component to it
now if we did want to start mocking up
some of this functionality we of course
are going to be using a Lambda fetch the
query to get access to the Lambda
function and that will actually be doing
our true and then setting that to false
but if we wanted to actually try to
model some of this type of stuff up this
becomes really important because when we
are trying to create these different
states of hey I'm waiting for
a quote and then I got it back how could
you actually model that out without
doing anything in the cloud just yet so
what we're going to do is we're going to
use a set timeout function to sort of
model how this would actually be working
so we're going to copy that function
we're going to do set timeout
we're going to log that as an arrow
function we're going to process
set processing quote to be
false
and then we're going to give that
and that will be for three seconds so
that we'll be able to sort of emulate
how this is actually going to
happen so when we make a quote
we're going to see this for three
seconds
about and then we're gonna see you know
our quote pop up here so obviously this
will be maybe faster much faster with
Lambda than three seconds but three
seconds will just give us a little bit
of an understanding of how to do that
and then of course
every time that we run this quote we're
going to run that function it's going to
be making this true and then three
seconds is going to be false so that
gives us a good understanding of how
this function is going to be operating
now what we want to do is we're going to
take
this child's component so this is just
the state one of processing the request
of the quote now we need to have if the
quote state is fulfilled so how do we
actually go and change that well we're
going to have something a little bit
different so we're going to have in that
same square different code
so now
if the quote
received is not null meaning that we
have something there
we'll use that
operator
will then make our separate div and then
we're going to start plugging away with
a download and
a visualization to show
where the quote is and then allow us to
interact with it
so we're going to do is we're going to
have a quote
generator title which we can copy from
there
we're then going to say download
your quote
then we're going to have another
opponent that says quote
generator or subtitle
and we're actually going to include
those same Styles there
we're going to say see a preview
close that out
and then we're going to have an image
blob container which is going to include
that image so image blob
container
and that's going to include some
elements
which we will Define in a little bit
and there's going to be an animated
download
button
and before we get
a little bit farther with these other
styles there was something that uh I do
want to just call out very quickly so
when you click on this quote
um
you'll see this white and then blue
border around this element so there this
is this default for Focus around outline
when you click on something so a way
that we can get rid of that in case you
see that on your screen is when we go to
quote generator modal container which is
the styled box we can add in this style
so when you use Styles components you
can use
and colon and then a class for a pseudo
class and then you can use these
brackets to then Define certain elements
so for outline we're going to choose non
and we're going to say important so we
never want to see outline and we want to
prioritize this in the Styles so as soon
as we press save
now this should go away but if we also
click on this now you won't see any of
that uh background and it's it's the out
of the border that we selected from
before also another thing is if when we
were writing this function we made it
where you have to click inside of this
text div so if you click on outside of
that it won't actually
um include it so something that we can
do is we can go back to where we call
that Handler so the handle open
generator
on click and we're just going to move
this out
to be
where the generate quote button lives so
that's where now we're just we just move
this function to include the whole div
so now anytime that you click on this
this model will pop up
even if you click on the text
or click or in the corner that will
still work and we can also just inspect
if this is styling in the mode in the
the mobile way that we are expecting so
we press this
that looks pretty good
and then if we expand this out a little
bit more
that looks great too so there's just a
couple other ways that we can test and
make sure that we are fully
checking out
the Styles and also refining the vision
of the application as we go along
now to switch back to
this state number two we're going to
want to finish out the rest of these
elements so for the image blob container
we're going to be creating
some animated elements
so the animated elements are going to
show us how we can make a little bit
more of an interactive view for our
actual application
so what we're going to want to do is
we're going to want to go here I'm going
to go to animations
I'm going to do image
blob TSX
and we're going to make a new functional
component so we're going to do rafce
and then we're going to react Arrow
functional expert component and then
we're going to call this image blob
and then in the top we're going to
import the image from next
image so we're going to be of course
working with the image module out of
next image and this is how we're going
to be animating our pop-up
so something that we're going to do is
we're going to work through some imports
for this component and then we're also
going to give it a style but something
that we can do right now is we'll just
have image blob here we'll give this a
save
we're then going to import
image blob from here so image blob
container
inside of this
we're then going to put an image blob
and there's going to be some
props that we passed down from here but
we will work on those in a little bit
and we'll
press enter so that we can import image
blob and then we're going to work on the
image blob container
styles
so in terms of animations we're going to
create a new file
we're going to call it
animation elements
TSX
and then this is where we're going to
move this to the right
and now we can start importing our
elements here and something also that we
can do since we already have quote
generated elements something that I
personally like to do is just
import our last recent Imports and then
just put those at the top and then we
can always remove certain ones that we
don't need we might need image we might
need link but we could keep those there
and then we're going to do exsc for the
export South component shortcut
and then we're going to do image blob
container
right there and then we're going to
start adding in our styles for the div
so we know that this is a div so put
that there and then I'm going to copy
our styles for this because this is
quite a lot of code here
and we'll put that in there and then
I'll walk through all of the code with
you
so when we have this image blob
container
can actually get rid of this because
that was some relative styling
for some testing so we originally had a
position of relative we have a text
align of Center meeting we want
everything to be in the middle this is
going to be down 10 from the top
um and then the margin top will have 20
pixels of some margin spacing we'll have
a transition this is going to be
important so when we do this on hover or
we're animating elements we want to give
this sort of a really Sleek ease and
ease out effect we also want the width
to fit the contents and we also want
margin Auto so just adding more
centering around horizontally and
vertically and then we also want to give
it a height of 100 pixels total and then
the Z index meeting make this go over
everything and prioritize that now for
the hover this is actually some pretty
cool Styles because when we hover over
this element this is how you do that in
styled components then when you
transform scale we're going to times
this by 4.8 so on the hover it's going
to grow by 4.8 and then of course the
index stays the same
then the transition we have this effect
so on the hover it Transitions and then
also on the out of hover so Mouse out
this will have a also a transition then
we have our box Shadow and then we also
have some media queries and these are
helpful because when we make our
our application our width and our height
you know change we want to be able to
change that as well so when the height
becomes 800 pixels maximum we only want
to scale it by 3.8 and then if it's only
600 pixels wide we want to only scale it
by 2.8 so this makes sure that you don't
expand it past the width of the screen
but that it's relative to a lot of these
other types of styles and then these of
course is just box Shadows uh around the
hover effect but these are important for
making sure that we don't
over scale the image when we expand it
so we can give this a save
and then
what we'll do is we'll then import this
like that and then that's how we can
easily import that there
and then we'll also start working on
this animated download button so this
animated download button is going to be
its own component
we're then going to create a new
functional component in animations so
we'll call this
animated download button.tsx
and we can actually just copy this from
here
and then just paste it in there just so
that we can start
tiling it and then
something also that you can do is that
if you have the same text in many
different places you can hold down the
control button and press D many times
and then that will allow us to have this
cursor so that if we wanted to
delete something we could do that
for example we can hover over all of
these images and then we can delete
there we go so then we just select and
then we press D delete and now we can
write that so we can write animated
download
button
and then now it's Auto writing these
dynamically which is a really helpful
hack so that you don't have to write and
then write and then write you could just
write them all at once so now we're
going to do is we are going to have this
give this a save we'll go back to our
generator there
and then we will import this so rewrite
the last letter press enter and then now
we have all those errors removed from
our application
or from our code
so I'll give that a save and then we
will keep proceeding here so the
animated download button is going to
have some pretty cool styles
that will be helpful for us and make our
application look kind of a little bit
cooler and more Dynamic but before we do
that let's just make sure that this
actually is
configured and it is working
so
we are going to say that
we want that to equal no because we want
to see if we can
show that
so when we make a quote so this is where
this will disappear and then this is
where that's going to be so you can see
that here where it's going to say
download your quote we'll have a preview
this image blob is going to have this on
Hover effect there and then we'll also
have this download button that will be
centered with some Styles and then this
will allow us to actually copy this
image that's there so it seems like
everything is working without any Styles
which is great so now we can keep
proceeding here
so before we forget we'll make sure that
we revert back to it not equaling null
we'll give that a save
and now we can proceed with our button
so if we go to the load button this is
going to be a function
functional component that we're going to
create so something that we're going to
do is we're going to use a pretty fun
package called react Lottie player
and this is going to allow us to install
this player for a Lottie image and a lot
of image is really just a Json object
and it will instead of being a static
image it allows an animation so what
we'll do is that we'll open up a new
terminal
we'll do npm I
and we'll say react Lottie player we'll
press enter
and then now we've installed it
so now what we can do is we can install
and import react body player from the
top
and then something also that we're going
to do is that we're going to
add
our react Lottie image into our
assets folder
so I'll show you what this looks like
and then
we go to Plug and Play so you don't have
to worry about copying this this is like
quite a lot of code but this is the
react Lottie image and this is what it
looks like so it's a huge Json object
that has all of these different
characters and all these different
things and what it's going to do is that
it allows for this animated
effect instead of it being a static
effect
so what we'll do is that we will say
We'll import
Lottie Json from and it's already
trying to find where it is but
we'll do assets
and then we're going to say animated
photo.json so that's that file
now we're going to do is we're going to
need to import it into our page so we're
going to get rid of this placeholder div
and then we're going to start adding
some elements so we're going to say
download
quote card container and then this is
going to have an on click
and it's going to have a button which
we're going to Define later so we'll
just say that this is null
this is container
card container
then we're going to have
Center Lottie which is going to be its
own South component
and we're going to give it a few
different styles so we're going to say
Loop because we want the image to Loop
and this is where we're going to be
working from
this Lottie package which you'll see in
a little bit but we wanted to Loop
we want animation data to equal the
Lottie Json image that we're importing
and then we also want to have it play
so we'll close that out
and then we're going to have another
style component that's going to say
download
quote card
context
for container text and then we're going
to say download
your quote cart
so that looks about right
and now we're going to do is we are
going to start working on
these styles
so for the first one which is d
download card so now we're in animation
elements
so what we're going to do is we're going
to control B and close it out we're then
going to open this up and then we're
going to have this on the side and we're
going to do exsc
we're going to say download
and we can actually just copy
from there this is going to be a div
and then we're going to copy our styles
from our CSS right here and that's what
that looks like so we're going to have
it have a porter we're going to give it
a width we're going to have its position
relative in the screen with a border
radius so the edges are rounded uh the
the cursor is going to be pointed when
you you know hover over it and then
there's going to be a margin there's
going to be transform just to kind of
get it in the width in the middle and
then there's going to be some on Hover
effects so it'll just be getting a box
Shadow backdrop filter there's going to
be some other aspects that we have to
this
we're then going to rewrite the last
letter
we'll then import that
and we can do is we can actually
just so the typescript won't complain
about this we'll just comment that out
for now
then for centered Lottie
what we're going to do is that we're
going to
copy
this Lottie
effect from here
we're then going to import this
from here
and then that's where we're going to be
using Lottie as a styled element so
we're going to do is we're going to do
exscc
we're going to say centered
Lottie and then this is going to be
styled
body
then we're going to do is we're going to
import these styles
so this will have a width a height it'll
be in the center it'll be a position
relative and then it'll margin minus 40
from the top and then pointer events is
going to have none just so that it's not
interfering with any click click events
inside of that so then
we'll press that
download quote card text
we're gonna do exsc
we're going to say this is a div
and then we're going to copy over our
Styles so we can write them so
this is now
color font family font size right a lot
of the good stylings that we would
expect text align we want that in the
center so the text is aligned we're
going to give it some padding margin top
minus 60 and of course for the max width
media query we're going to be making the
font a little bit smaller as the screen
gets smaller
so then we'll rewrite this last letter
we'll rewrite that we'll give our
elements a save and then we'll give this
a save
then we're going to go back to here
and then we are just going to
make this equal one more time just so
that we can test this out
we're then going to move this over
so now what's really cool is that we
have this button where
you see that this image is moving up and
down in a loop
so I think that's pretty cool because
what makes our application now more fun
is that of course we have this on Hover
effect here but also this image is you
know sparkling it's moving and that's a
lot of image so you can learn more about
Lottie images if you if you start
googling
um there's a website called icon Scout
and you can get a whole bunch of these
different Lottie images many of them for
free and this was just one that I
thought looked really nice and just kind
of it brings your app to life because
now it's not just a download button now
you have a download button with a cool
animation and it also makes you know
your app a little bit more interactive
for your users so that it's more fun so
now that we have that that's pretty cool
so now we're going to start working on
this other element which is going to be
how we actually see
the preview image of our element so this
is going to be that image blob and we'll
work on that next so now we're at a good
spot where we can start taking our code
sandbox code pushing that to Lambda and
now we can actually try to get this
image blob to then come back into our
application so the way this is going to
work is that when we actually get a
quote received this can't be no so we're
going to switch that back and we're
going to be getting the string back from
Lambda and then we're going to be
basically having it in this image blob
component and then we'll be able to work
from that as soon as we get that passed
back from our Lambda code so we switch
this back now we're going to do is we're
going to pass in two specific variables
so we're going to pass in these two
props into our application so quote
received that's going to be what we
passed down which you'll see from the
top
we pass that down as a property into
this child's component and then blob URL
it's not going to know what blob URL is
yet but but we're going to be passing
this down
uh from our
Lambda code and then that's going to
exist once this function is invoked and
then we save that in state
so what we're going to do is
we're going to go back to
our values here
we're then going to say const
blob URL set blob
URL
equals use state
this is going to be either a string or
it'll be null because we won't get a
value
and then this will be set to be no from
the beginning and then we're going to
import use state
as a hook
and while we're here
we'll also import use effect because we
know we're going to need this in a
little bit
so now that we have blob URL now we're
going to be able to
work from the function to actually get
this
so
something that we can do is that we're
going to write two specific functions
the first is going to be that handle
download
so we can write so function
for handle handling
the download of quote card and then also
we need a function
to handle
the receiving
of quote card
so to handle the download something
we're going to do is that we are going
to say const handle download
this is going to be an arrow function
we're then
given a link
we're going to say document
create element a
and then we're going to say if the type
of
blob URL
equals a string
then what we're going to do is that
we're going to have this code so there's
going to be a link there's going to be
an href and then we're going to set that
as a link the link will have a download
which we will have as quote.png which is
the file name and then will allow us to
click click into that link
so this is going to be a function that
will be able to then have so when we
call
and we said download your quote
we could have the animated download
button down here
of course that and then we'll say handle
download
so
we can actually close out these Styles
because we don't need them right now
so now we're going to pass this down
to the animated download button
we'll pass that in another property and
we're going to need to create our own
interface for this because it's not
going to understand
from a typescript perspective what we
want that function to actually do
so something that we can do is that we
can say animated
download button props
something also that we can do is that we
can do on click and we'll just pass that
down and then we're going to declare as
an interface here we'll say interface
animated download but props
and then we're going to say handle
download
and then this is how we will Define this
type for the function
so that looks great so far and then
we'll be able to actually use this
download button to handle the download
that we pass down through here so that
will work great now we need to do is we
need to also work on a function to
handle the receiving of that quote
so this is going to be important because
when we get this string back from Lambda
we're going to need to do something with
it and we're going to need to allow us
to either add this in as the blob URL or
revoke and remove it so that we can re
re-add a new link so this is where when
you fetch a new quote each time we need
to clear out basically the placeholder
for that old quote to make space for the
new quote so tonight we're going to do
is we are going to use that use effect
hook to then allow us to work from
this functioning a little bit more
smoothly because we want to be able to
just instantly get
this string and then allow us to get
this quote
so we'll do is that we will
set this up just like a normal use
effect hook
we'll pass this in and now we're going
to say if
quote received
then
we're going to want to do some code and
I think it's also important to get into
practice of if you have this
and also make sure that we close out
and unsubscribe from this use effect so
that we don't have this running
you know an unlimited number of times
all the time
so this is just going to say that run
this if quote received is changing
so then what we can do is we can say
const we're going to say binary data
equals and then we're going to use
buffer
Dot from we'll say quote received
okay say base 64.
so we're going to be using
some dependencies that we're going to be
using to work with a base 64 encoded
string
now when we do const blob we know this
is going to be a new blob
and the blob is going to be a locally
stored
aspect of code that we're then going to
be basically storing in local storage or
clearing out and then adding a new one
each time
so when we take this new blob element
we're going to add in binary data
we're then going to say that the type is
going to be image
Dot
image.png
then we're going to do is we're going to
say const blob
URL generated
equals URL
dot create
object URL
blob
we'll then console log that value just
so that we can keep track of
what's actually being generated and then
we're going to set blob URL
to also be
blob URL generated
so these are going to be the different
values and then we're going to be using
use state to set the blob URL and then
we're going to do is we're going to
return
we're going to make this into a function
and then we're going to say URL dot
revoke object URL and then we're going
to also have blob URL there so basically
this is going to be setting and then
removing the old blob URL generated each
time that we we run this so we want to
make sure that
if a Court's received we take this new
data that we receive we set that as the
blob URL and then we remove and revoke
that old URL that we were previously
received
and that'll also become important so
that you don't just store an unlimited
number of these blob URLs in your local
storage but they are always constantly
cleaning out the old URL each time as
you proceed and that's what we'll be
doing here
so that seems great for now and now
something that we can do is we can also
just make sure that
for the quote received if we're passing
the image blob URL down to have these
values so things like I'll copy this
say image blob URL
and then what we're going to do is that
we're going to make sure that we have an
interface to store those values so if
you remember from before
we have these two values here so I'm
just going to comment those out
so we know that blob URL
image blob is going to need
received and it's going to need the blob
URL
then we're also going to need to create
an interface so we'll say image blob
props
then what we'll do is we'll say We'll
click declare an interface enter
face
props and then we'll pass these both
down
and then for this one
quote uh received this is going to be a
string
and then for
blob URL this could either be a string
or it can be null
because this Bob URL doesn't necessarily
need to have a value but as soon as it
does have a value we want to make sure
that we know that that there is a value
there
so this is all good now we do this we'll
go back to quote generator
we'll say quote received
and we'll just see that there is
an error here and it's going to say that
it's string not assigned to string type
but string is a wrapper so we'll see
here so we'll go back
and we'll make this
capital S for Capital string and then
that will remove that error so there are
differences in terms of the type of
string it can be so just be cognizant of
that when you're working with typescript
to make sure that if you are
typing out your values you need to make
sure that those are correctly typed
which we're doing which is great
so to do that we'll give this a save
we'll give this a save we'll give this a
save and something that we can do is
mock up how the response is going to be
for when we are getting this image back
from our Lambda script so we've talked a
lot about base64 and now we're actually
going to see what this looks like but to
do this what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create
a variable called blob URL
and we're just going to bring this down
and then we're going to just unhighlight
that for a second we're then also going
to import some hooks
and then what we're going to do is to
enter and then we're going to write a
pretty big use effect hook and it's
going to simulate us fetching this
response object from Lambda which is
what we'll be doing we'll get this
string and then we're going to show how
we can actually set that image
in our application
so we're going to do is we're going to
do use effect
or say const response
and then the response object is going to
have a number of different variables but
what we're going to really look for is a
status code
of 200
in terms of headers
we would have a content
type
which would be image.png
and then access
control allow
origin
which will give a wild card for
everything
and then our body response we're gonna
have a body
which is going to be a blob
and then is base 64 encoded we're going
to say that's true
get rid of that backslash and then for
the body so this body is going to be a
very very very very very long string
and this is actually the first time that
you're actually going to see what a
base64 encoded string looks like
so you don't have to worry about writing
this down we're gonna I'll show you how
to get this in Lambda so that you don't
actually have to do it
but it's going to look something like
this monstrosity
so this huge list of characters is what
an image looks like so when we have an
image
it can either be you know a file like a
PNG or a JPEG but if we wanted to turn
this into a code string that's another
way to also get an image so this base64
encoded string really looks just like
this and this
all these characters all of this code
compiles down to an image that we can
then set and then use in our application
so also just showing back here so we
have this response object inside of our
use effect hook
so let's scroll down to where it stops
so it stops here
now we're going to do is we're going to
say const binary
data equals buffer
Dot from
we're going to say response body because
that's what the this is what the body
variable is say response that body and
we say base 64.
then we're going to say blob because we
need a blob variable and we're going to
say that's a new blob
this is going to be binary data
and then the type is
response dot headers
with the content type
close out the bracket
and we'll get rid of that
quotation mark
and then we're going to take our blob
and then put that into a new blob URL so
we'll say const new blob
your Rel equals URL
create object URL
and we'll put blob in there and then
we're going to do is we are going to set
blob URL with that new blob URL that we
just got
then we're going to return
as an arrow function
URL revoke
object
URL
with the new blob URL
so I'll be able to clear out
this value every time that we set that
and then what we'll do is we will make
sure to unsubscribe from this event so
every time that the page loads this will
load and it's saying that this
can't find set blob URL so we're going
to go back up to the top
and we're going to make sure
that we're able to set this
and if it's not being read
that means that we are not importing it
correctly
so this might be typescript being a
little bit slow here
so something that we can do is we see
that it's not um it's not working as
quickly as possible so something that we
can do is we can try saving this
and then what we can do is we can press
command shift p we can reload the window
and sometimes this is a way to sync up
typescript changes
just so that we can
work a little bit faster so sometimes
when you're doing a lot of typescript
changes or errors I've noticed that
sometimes you need to do that reload
window just to get your workspace and vs
code synced up with typescript so that
it works so you can always use that just
as a check in case you ever have any
issues or ever have any errors so now
that we have use effect
something that we'll also do now is
we'll do if and we'll create a check
where we need the blob URL
we'll create this we'll do return
no
and then we're going to create an object
so we're going to remove that we're
going to create an image
component with The Blob
URL
and some alt which is going to say alt
text which is going to say generated
image we'll just say image quote card
with
we're going to give that a 150
and a height
we're going to give that as 100.
so and then we export our default image
blob and this seems pretty good
so what we're going to do is we're going
to give this a save we're then going to
open up our application
in another Tab and something that we are
going to do is we're first going to
because of course we're going to be
testing
so we're going to do make a quote that's
going to generate right it's going to
time out after three seconds and now
we're going to do is we're going to go
back to our page
to our quote generator we're then going
to say if this equals no because we
actually haven't set quote received yet
we're going to give that a save
and now we actually have what is going
to be
this preview so if we click on this so
to see how this is
you know making the the background sort
of blur it out and
not as uh not as seeable and we actually
see this image so what's really cool
about the URL is that if we open this
image in a tab
so this is a real image that we can take
we can drag we can move around with and
that's what that blob is doing so it's
creating this blob HTTP localhost 3000
and then it gives it this unique ID so
that we can identify this in our local
storage so that's why if you took this
you could do copy image you could save
this image you can open it up in a new
tab or copy text from image or copy
image address and that's all because we
have this image and we can also see this
if we inspect it
we see that its source is now that so if
we go back to our to our code
so down here
we have this image with the source which
is the blob URL so the actual blob URL
is this and that's what we generated
with that base 64 encoded string so we
take that really long crazy string of
characters and then that is what gets
compiled down into a blob and we use
buffer along with a couple other modules
to then turn that into an image that we
can then
save in our local storage which is
awesome so this is exactly how we're
gonna work and then we're going to have
this download your quote button to
download this image once we get this
back from Lambda but this is the
functionality and also just to show you
some of the styling that we set up from
before so as we make this smaller and
make this
more like a mobile application and we
put that in the middle
so now if we try to make a quote
obviously we'll see that there we won't
see that when we go there but do you see
how now this is smaller and this is more
contained in here and then if we hover
over this this hover is actually
smaller than the than the hover if the
screen was expanded and we'll see that
again
to the here so this is much bigger than
what we just showed on the mobile view
so that's how media queries become
really important when we are working
with our Styles because then we're able
to actually dynamically change how the
style looks based upon the width of the
screen so you'll have a different mobile
experience than a desktop experience
which makes sense because you have
different widths on both of those
screens so that's great so now we're
going to be able to go back to our code
and now we can start working on the
script to receive this data from Lambda
and then what we'll do is instead of
getting this base64 string locally right
we're going to be getting this in AWS
Lambda returning back as a response so
we're going to get a response object but
it won't be locally stored it's going to
be sent from our API through Lambda into
our application and then decoded in the
front end with typescript so it'll be
the same exact process except we're
actually going to get a blob URL that
will be from
not a response locally but it'll be from
AWS so now that we have worked on this
local testing of our inspirational quote
generator let us of course get into the
habit of doing another save
so that we can
start working from here so
I'm going to do control Z
just to make that a little bit smaller
and now we're going to say
local
or say add
local mock of
quote however
image blob
so we'll make a commit to that
we'll push origin
and now we're ready to go so now that
we're in a good spot with the front end
now let us work on the Lambda function
that we're going to be using to generate
this this code for our quotes
so when you go to your amplify folder
there's a number of different subfolders
but we're going to go to back end
we're not going to go to API but we're
going to go to function and we'll go to
inspo quote Lambda which is what we just
generated a while back now we're going
to go to the index.js file and now we're
able to see
a starter
template for our hello from Lambda
function so basically what this is doing
is that we're going to import types for
AWS Lambda
through an API Gateway proxy Handler and
then we have our exports Handler which
is an async event and then this is just
going to console log the event so it's
important to think about each of these
every time that when you run a Lambda
function that's an event and you can
pass in data or test or input AWS Json
into that event and then you'd be able
to process it so you could do batch
processing inside of a Lambda you could
return a status code of 200 kind of like
our response object from before so you
could return a response you could just
generate code in AWS and then have it do
something and then there's nothing
returned back really it's up to you in
terms of how you want to configure your
serverless scripts but for us we're
going to be returning a response back to
the user and that's going to be that
that body response that we had before
which is going to be that base64 encoded
string so what we're going to do is that
we're going to first open up
package.json and we're going to see
what's already installed with us so we
have a name description the main file is
going to be that index.js we have a
license and we have some Dev
dependencies but we're going to also
need to install some actual real
dependencies so we're going to do is
that we're going to open up the terminal
we're going to open up a new line we'll
say clear
and now we're going to do is that we're
going to do CD
we're going to drag this Source folder
here so drag the path press enter and
now if we do LS this is where we're in
this directory
for
this location so now we're going to do
is that we're going to clear this and
then we're going to do npm I and then
we're going to install some dependencies
so we're going to want
to do npm I so go back there so we're
going to want to do types at types node
we're going to want to install node
Fetch and it's going to be a very
specific version of node because we will
need this for our Lambda if you do node
Fetch and it's version three this won't
work in Lambda because of how this is
configured for
the certain type of
node.js that we're going to be using we
need to make sure that we use version
two
because we use require statements so we
need to make sure that we abide by that
we also need to install path
and we also need to install sharp and
sharp was that library that we were
using to composite our image together so
we're going to do npmi
and install these packages together
and then this might take a couple of
minutes
and then we should see the printout
there so now if we make this smaller we
should see that all the packages
installed correctly as we'd expect now
what we can do is we can open back up
our
node.js index.js file and now we can
start plugging away with our function so
there are some things that we're going
to need to do when we are turning our
code sandbox code so this code
into something that can work with
Lambda so we have these packages that
are installed right we have our our six
steps
we have our get random quote function
we have that SVG right we have all these
things and then we run get random quote
so to take all of this code we're not
going to be able to just import that
into this Lambda function just like that
we are going to need to make a few
modifications but
promise it's not that many things so
something that we are just going to do
is we're going to need to install some
packages
so we're going to declare AWS
I'm going to say require
let me say AWS SDK
and something that we're going to need
to do for our Lambda function is
something that I think is really cool so
when we are working with any sort of AWS
service we need to allow for resource
access controls so this is going to
allow us to and these are really IEM
statements or confirmation template
modifications but when we want to have a
Lambda
speak to our database we're going to
need to create resource access to allow
Lambda to speak to Dynamo so the reason
of why we're going to do this is that of
course we need to run our code and
generate the image but if you remember
from before we wanted to enable a way
where as you run this function we want
to then update the database
but that specific database object that
we created before if you remember that
quotes generated number we want to
increment that by plus one every time
that this function executes and that's a
really cool way where you could have
serverless code sort of that event
driven architecture where something
happens in a script that then modifies
the database or you could have it where
a database object happens and then a
script runs it's really up to you in
terms of how you are interested in event
driven architectures highly would
recommend checking out dynamodb streams
it's a very very cool way to enable that
event driven architecture within a
database context and then with Lambda
we're going to be checking out our
resource access permissions to connect
Lambda to Dynamo
so we're going to be doing a couple of
things here
but to specifically to allow
our Lambda function to speak to Dynamo
what we're going to need to do is that
we're going to open up the terminal
again
we're going to do and we can actually
close this
uh this terminal Window app because we
don't need it anymore
what we're going to do is that we're
already here we could do amplify update
function
and I will bring this up just so that we
can see this a little bit more easily so
there's only one function here that we
can select from so we'll do inspo quote
Lambda
now what's a really great feature about
the AWS amplify framework is that it's
already pulling in all of the data about
our inspo quote Lambda it knows that
this is a node.js runtime and then it
gives us some information about what
we've set up so we need to focus on the
resource access permissions because this
is going to allow us to speak to our
database so what we're going to do is
that we're going to do resource access
permissions
we need to focus on storage
which is our data now what we need to do
is that we want to be able to read and
we want to be able to update so we're
going to be able to read the database
object and then we also want to update
it so we're going to update it by
incrementing by plus one the number of
quotes that were generated each time
that the function runs so we're going to
select those two options with the space
bar and then go down and then press
spacebar and then you see that they're
highlighted we're going to press enter
and do you want to edit the Lambda
function now we're going to say yes
and then we'll press enter to continue
and then it will be up here
so now we're going to do is that there
might be a little bit of a difference
between what you were writing in your
Lambda code and then what
amplify and the CLI just generated for
us so if you ever try to save this you
might get an error where it says the
content of the file is newer so what we
can do is that we can compare
and we see here that these were the
Imports that amplify CLI wanted to add
to our file but we had this code so
something that we can do which is a
handy shortcut is we'll press copy we'll
copy this code
and then we'll just we'll just exit out
of this what we want to do is that we
want to include this code into our file
and not this so it will do is that we're
going to say discard your changes and
revert to the file contents so that
button and now
we see that these are the Imports that
the amplify CLI generator for us and
we can still you know bring in our code
from before so what's awesome about this
is that what amplify just did was it
added these environmental variables so
that we can pull from them and use them
in our code and we don't need to hard
code the table name or you know the Arn
or the graphql API output we don't need
to do any of that or the environment of
the region we're able to just pull these
in as environmental variables and this
is the real power of building with a CLI
like amplify because we're able to just
work so quickly with our serverless
architecture and really scale out
systems without needing to second guess
you know is this the right variable is
this the right name we're able to just
pull all these in pretty pretty quickly
and also make sure that it is all code
that is correct which is great so now to
get these AWS
packages
this is how we're going to do the AWS
components and then we're also going to
have the image generation
packages
so to do the AWS things we're going to
need the AWS SDK but just a handy thing
to note is you don't need to do npm
install AWS SDK this is actually a
pretty big package and you wouldn't want
to necessarily install that into your
pack.json there actually is a scope down
way in which the Lambda is actually able
to know these different parts of the AWS
SDK so you don't actually it's baked
into the Lambda so you don't actually
need to install it directly it'll just
know when you call hsdk it'll just know
what you need there are some exceptions
though with certain services so you just
might need to be aware of you might need
to install you know AWS SDK slash client
slash something just to get certain
packages for certain services but
dynamodb is one that we can already use
that's baked into Lambda so we're going
to do cons dot client and this is how
we're going to create a new dynamodb
client that we can work from so do new
AWS Dot
dynamodb
dot document client and something that's
also interesting about
the um Amazon code Whisperer which I was
using it was Auto it was already trying
to auto complete the region
but we don't actually need to do that
because
if we try to install
um so basically because we're using
Lambda with amplify the Region's already
programmed into the Lambda so it'll know
that we just need to install
you know and run this specific AWS
dynamodb document client and then it'll
know that that's where that's what we're
working from so now under the image
generation packages
we're gonna do cons Sharp
and we can actually probably just copy
some of these from before
so we'll do here
and we'll do cons Sharp
and then also for fetch
but you can copy that one
so require node Fetch and then we are
going to need to do those other ones so
const path equals require
path which you'll see
later on when we use that and then const
FS
will require
and I'm just going to make
single quotes for all of these just to
make it a little bit more organized
great okay cool
so now we're going to do is that outside
of this Handler we're going to write our
function that's going to update our
dynamodb so we'll say function
update
dynamodb
table
for the function that we're going to
write for our updating dynamodb table
we're going to write an async function
and we'll call it update
quote dynamodb object
and then we're going to have our const
quote table
name variable and that's where we're
going to pull
our inspirational quote table name and
that's from dynamodb but this is how
we're using our environmental variables
to then call this
so we're going to do process
.env Dot
that table name and that's uh
environmental variable that was created
for us by the amplify CLI now we're
going to do quants quote
object ID
and that's where we're going to go back
to dynamodb and we're going to
copy that
and that's where we're going to have a
string
for this value
so we want to modify this specific
object in our database and this is the
database name
now we're going to put a try catch
and we're going to do catch
the error
and we'll of course console log
error updating quote object in Dynamo
and then we'll log that error
so the actual code that we're going to
be using is we're going to be using this
params method to then update
using a promise our dynamodb so it's
already kind of constructing this value
but we'll go through this together
so when we do this we're going to do
create a variable we'll call it quote
params
let's meet object so then there'll be a
table name
which we'll call quote table name
there'll be a key
which we'll call ID
and that's going to be quote object ID
then we're going to have an update
expression
and that's going to be a set
and we're going to call this quote
generated
because that's going to be the value and
we're going to make that equal to
quotes generated plus a value that we're
going to increment and that's where the
Inc is going to come in
then the expression
at tribute value
is going to be this
so there's going to be an
increment
and that'll be one
so we're basically taking this value and
updating
the update expression to then include a
one so it's going to be the quote
generated equals close generated already
Plus 1.
and these are going to be the same
values so that will work great so now
we're going to do is we're going to
continue along we're going to say that
there is an expression
attribute names
and then we're going to say quotes we
can actually just copy this in case that
makes that easier so quotes generated
is
quartz generated
and then there's going to be a return
values
which is going to be updated
new
so we're going to be focused only on
updating the new value every time that
this runs
then what we're going to do is that
we're going to
use this value
this quote params
when we're calling this Lambda function
so we're going to do is we'll do const
update quote object
equals a weight because we need to await
this function with your dot client
dot update
pass in those quote params
into the update
do you promise
and then we're going to return
update quote object
and that's how we're going to be able to
use this specific function
in our Lambda script
and then of course we're catching any
errors where this doesn't work out
that's great so now we're going to do is
we're going to Now work on getting our
code from code sandbox into our exports
Handler so we can actually start
doing the image composition as well but
of course we can give this a save so
we'll keep our console log for our event
in there because we still want to track
when events get
created every time that we run the
Lambda so now we're going to do is that
we're going to go back to code sandbox
and
we're going to need this API URL because
that's going to be important for when we
use this inside of our event handler
we're going to need to call the API
random from Zen quotes
then what we're going to do is that
we're going to go back here and then
we're going to take
all of this code
copy that
we're then going to put that
here
so we're going to do
generate
the function
so put that in there
and we're going to need to make some
changes here to how we're actually
calling this because before we would
just call this and then we'd be done but
instead of generating an image we're
going to need to generate this base64
string so that we can actually export
that as a response and then the user
will be able to see that so everything
here is going to basically be the same
we have our quote text we have our quote
author we have our response which we're
going to
you know await and then fetch from the
API input
or here which is that and then we're
going to need to pass that in so we'll
just need to be cognizant of passing
that into the function since this is
the function that we're going to call
but we put that we pass that in then the
quote data is going to be some
response.json and that everything else
is looking pretty good right we have our
SVG image which we're passing in we've
already constructed this we know that
this works
but of course we're going to need to
create some backgrounds because these
backgrounds don't exist in the Lambda
function yet so what we're going to do
is that we're going to in our
inspirational quote Lambda we're going
to create a folder we're going to call
it backgrounds
and then we're going to copy
those images that we already have from
our
assets folder
which should be here
but if you didn't already save them then
we'll just need to open that up in our
finder
which you already probably have these
saved locally
and then I will just copy these and put
these into here
and now we have the file here so
file here file here file here and then
those become the backgrounds that we add
so now when we call background images
it's going to know that we're in here
backgrounds and then it'll find those
backgrounds in the folder
so now we're going to do is that we are
going to then go through random index
we do all of those constructions that we
generated before and we tested we know
that this works
and now we're going to do is that we're
going to need to do
a few changes here so this is where
we're composing the image together we're
going to need to make sure that we don't
necessarily save it as an image
but we're going to then save it as a
string so we're going to do is that
we're going to we we have the time stamp
but we won't actually really need that
anymore because we're not going to be
using the timestamp but we are going to
create
this image path
so this image path is going to be
not necessarily the file right we're
going to be creating an image that is a
string and then we're going to pass that
out so we're going to do path dot join
TMP and that's for temporary storage so
this is how we're going to be able to
pass
this string or this this image into our
script
next up what we're going to do is we're
going to give this quote card.png
and
what we can do is we'll still have this
that SVG is still
SVG buffer is still there but we're
really focused on this image path that's
going to really be like the next part
and you know we still sort of have that
that image construction from before but
we can kind of pass this up so I'm sort
of doing a little bit of organizing here
just so you can see what the elements
are that are really important so these
are really Legacy from before and then
our new Focus we're focus on is this
path.join now we're going to do is
that
could actually see how that was
connected there but now when we do image
path what we're going to do is that
we're going to do image we're going to
do composite do SVG I'm going to say
instead of finals quote card timestamp
we're actually going to do image path
so you can see how like that applied to
the other ones before but why we have it
here is that we're taking this image
path
in temporary storage we're then going to
put it with the image path
and then what we're going to do is that
we're going to do some updating to
our Dynamo
and then also
run this response as the output so what
we'll do is that we'll do update
basically function
update
dynamodb object in table
and then we'll do try
and catch our
we'll say
unquote this that looks good
and
now in our try catch we're going to do
update
quote Dynamo to be object and that'll be
a function
and then we're going to return
this as an output
after our try catch so after this try
catch with the error we'll then do that
and we're going to be
turning some code so we're going to turn
status of 200
we're going to have some headers
and
Access Control allow origin we're going
to want this one
I'm not going to need headers for this
but what we will need is content
type
and that's going to be
image.png
which is the type we expect
and then after headers
can
do some formatting here
now for the body
instead of it being this
we're going to need to do FS dot read
file sync
the image path
and then we'll say two string and then
this is where we make it a base
64 encoded string
and then we'll say is base
64. encoded and we're going to make that
true
we close that out
we do that and then we're going to say
return
I'll wait
get random quote
API URL
and that will round out the rest of our
landscript so let's go back and unpack
really what we're doing here because
this is like quite a lot of things that
we are changing we're updating so we
have this function here and we'll just
close this out just so that we can see
that
so
we have this function
in here and we have this API input so
what we will do is that
given the series given this input into a
function we want to fetch this random
quote and then use that in our in our
quote card so when we take this we
basically pass this in and here and then
that's where we're going to be then this
function is a construction of two
different functions which is hey make
this quote but then also update Dynamo
and that's why we're running this
because this is going to be important
for our script and we get that function
up here
so it has all of this code here and then
that's what we're going to be updating
so now when we run our exports Handler
this is going to be all of the code that
we run
and we have our backgrounds we have all
of these things and also just to go
through
some of this timestamp some of this SVG
buffering so when we have SVG buffer
we want a buffer from the SVG image
that's what we had before but then we
have this image path where we say
path.join we put it into TMP and then we
have quote card PNG as the name then
under const image we're going to await
with sharp the selected background image
we then composite with the input is the
SVG buffer and then that's how we're
constructing it and then we say to file
path which is image path
and then we're going to be doing our try
catch which is going to be updating our
dynamodb object
and then we'll of course catch that if
there's an error updating Dynamo and
then we're going to return a status code
of 200 with the headers that we expect
and that's going to be content type of
image PNG which is that's how we would
be getting this base64 string and in the
access control allow origin is that and
then in the body which is going to be
some Json we get back we're going to
have FS for read file sync which is
going to include that image path we're
going to put that to string and that's
going to be base64. and then we say is
basically for encoded meaning true so
that we know that this is what the
response object is going to be
and then we're going to return a weight
and we're going to get random quote with
the API so that we're able to fully
construct
this script and get it to work
so that's going to look great when we
actually have this running live and now
what we can do is that we'll give this a
save
we'll then pull up
amplify status
and now we're going to do is that
we're going to check this out we're
going to see
that this function that we're working on
has an update operation so now we know
that we're able to push this so we're
going to do amplify
push
and this is where we're going to be able
to update our cloud formation stack with
this change
and we're going to say yes
and now it's going to update our cloud
formation stack to update that function
and then our Lambda function our Lambda
script will be updated in the Lambda
console in AWS for us using our cloud
formation stack updates
all through the amplify CLI so I'm going
to pause recording and then I'll resume
it when the function is updated
so that really didn't take very much
time at all I think it took maybe a
minute it actually might have been
actually less but now we have all of our
you know function updates that are
needed and especially that resource
permission between our dynamodb table
and Lambda so now if we go back to
Lambda console and we actually go and
search for this function we're going to
see that this was updated three minutes
ago which was what we just did so we're
going to click on this
and now we see that this is the function
that we're going to be working from also
something that is just interesting to
note is when we updated our permissions
for our function we were updating our
execution role for our Lambda function
but now we have this resource for Dynamo
so you can also look at buy action
or you can also look at by resource and
I think that this is helpful to see
where now we allow access to get or
update and that's something that our
Lambda function now has access to
and you can see these maybe a little bit
better but these are all of the
functions that we're able to then call
or the resources permissions that we're
able to call
such as listing or getting or updating
and this is why we're going to be able
to update our dynamodb table
because we added that permission to
allow Lambda to speak to Dynamo so this
is just helpful to think about when we
have this Lambda script what's actually
happening in the background which is
great so now we're going to do is we
want to configure a test because we want
to see if this code actually worked so
our code is going to be too big to see
because when we when you start working
with you know Lambda scripts and
um and functions sometimes you won't be
able to see the code because it's just
like there's just too much for it to to
show in the online editor but we already
have the code locally so we know what
it's doing so we're going to do is that
we're going to create a new event to
test this and see if we can get that
base64 string to export so we're going
to say
hello Bass 64.
and this is going to be a private event
and we
just need to really pass in something we
don't really need it to pass in anything
we just need to be able to invoke it
so we'll do is that we will
save this as a test
oh and we'll get rid of that
that comma and I'll be able to save it
so now
we can start running
we go to test
and this is where we're going to be able
to be testing our Lambda script
and see if we can get back a response
so we see that something happened with
sharp and it did not like something that
we installed so this will actually be a
good opportunity for us to then go and
see what's actually happening with sharp
and the package so that we can actually
debug this and fix it
so when you see these errors this can be
very helpful because Lambda will try to
give us some helpful data back about
what's actually going wrong
so it's saying that it can't find the
module for Sharp
and it requires some elements here
so what we're going to do is that it'll
give some possible solutions such as
logging install this this all this but
something that actually I think is a
little bit sometimes more helpful
instead of getting the the log here is
that what we can do is we can go to
monitor we can go to cloudwatch logs
and then we're going to be able to
actually see
where our function is breaking down so
with cloudwatch logs this is a really
really helpful tool for checking out
when your functions are running or you
have processes in AWS and you need to
see basically what's going on
you can click on this and then it's
going to give you
information on
what actually is is happening inside of
your function so what we see is that we
see this undefined error
where it says something was wrong
installing the sharp module and it can't
find module sharp Linux this so there's
actually a very interesting way in which
we're going to need to install sharp for
AWS so we're going to switch back to
our Lambda script
and we're going to open up this
package.json
and we're going to actually explain how
to install sharp in a way that can speak
with Lambda in the Linux environment
that it's expecting
to get the correct package of sharp that
we're going to need for our Lambda
script I'm on the sharp dot
pixelplumbing.com install and they have
a module on high performance node.js
image processing and it talks about for
serverless ES build you need to make
sure that you install with this correct
Arch x64 and then platform Linux sharp
command so this is going to be important
because when we just install sharp
normally
it has its own configuration but we need
to make sure that we install this in the
right way so that when we use our Lambda
server this
environment will actually be able to
understand how to use sharp because
that's the real issue that we were
getting was we didn't install the right
version of sharp for the environment
that we need so the way in which we're
going to fix this is we're going to do
npm remove Sharp
but we have to actually CD into that
folder
so we'll press clear we'll do CD we're
going to
drag and drop Source folder
LS and then we see that we're in the
right space which is great so now we're
going to do is we're going to do npm
remove
Sharp
and that's going to remove that package
in the dependencies list now we're going
to do if we're going to do npmi we're
going to do dash dash Arch equals x64
and then we're going to do dash dash
platform equals Linux and then we'll
install Sharp
so we'll install that
and we'll wait for the package to
install correctly
and now what we'll do is
we will X Out of This terminal and now
we can do is we can do
amplify status
and if it doesn't register any changes
because it might just see that
sharp is the same and it's all installed
correctly so what we can do is that we
can just go back to our function we can
literally just add a space we'll press
save
and then we'll run that again
and we'll see if
it's registering so that's just an easy
way where if you add you know changes to
your package.json you can still then
just add a space save it to the Lambda
function and then they'll be able to
register and update something also
that's important that we're going to
need to do is we're going to need to
bring this backgrounds folder inside of
source
so we're going to move that in there
and now under Source will be able to
reference
these files
relative to where we are so that's where
we'll be able to then go back up to
backgrounds and then pull these images
down so this is also one of those
examples where
we are able to you know make some
changes that are similar to code sandbox
like before we could just have this
backgrounds folder free floating but we
actually need to put it inside of the
source because we're using that inside
of this index.js file so we're going to
do is we're going to now once we've made
those updates we'll do amplify
status
and our photos updated we'll do amplify
push and then we're going to update our
code with the file construction and then
also with the changes that we made to
the script
and then we'll be able to test in Lambda
once more to see if we're able to
generate that base64 encoded string and
send that as a response outside of the
Lambda
so now that our cloud formation stack
has been updated once again we are going
to go over to our Lambda function
we're going to refresh it
and now we're going to do is we are
going to go to testing and we're going
to run this test again and we're going
to see if this worked
so we see a much better message that we
got this working okay so now what we're
going to do is we are going to check
this out so we got a status quo of 200
we got an image PNG and we got you know
basically this response object that we
were supposed to get and then we have a
body and this is the
super super super long string of our
base64 encoded string so we can actually
check this out by testing it and seeing
if it's giving us a new
a new code
a new quote so we're gonna do is we're
going to give this a copy we're going to
go back to our front end
we're going to
close that terminal window
and then we're going to go back to where
our image blob is
so in this previous example
we had a body here
now what we want to do is
we want to add this here
and we're going to basically do the same
thing
and we're going to see if we can get
this to show
that still says null so then we're going
to go back here
and we're going to see if we can get a
new quote and it looks like we did but
we're just going to test this anyway
we're going to see you know this is the
loading State there
okay so this is great so we have our new
quote there and that seems like that's
working and we can try to do this one
more time and see if it's going to give
us another quote
so
we can do another test
coming up to the top
and looks like we'll get a new quote
here
so we'll go back here
we'll go back and we can actually
move some of that stuff around we'll
close this out
we'll then say body
and then add quote there we already have
a quote at the end of that
and this can just go to the
end of that
and we'll do blob
and looks like we got another one
so that's great and then let's see if we
can get just another image with another
background just to see if that is
working
so we'll do another test
it looks like the max memory was used so
we're going to
try going again
yeah so it seems like that's all working
great so we'll do another test
we have our next
image here
we'll copy that
bring that over to the front end
and we'll do the body again
and
we'll do quotes
put a comma behind there and we'll do
that again
we'll save that
and we'll go to our front end alright
great so we are getting you know a
random background assigned and we're
getting random quotes with the text the
author our footer and our image so this
is working great so now we know that
we're able to take our Lambda function
generate the base64 encoded string and
then pass that back in the front end
you know using you know the buffer
method and then we turn this into a URL
and another test that we can do is
we can open this image in a new tab
and this is actually going to open up
so now we can do is we can refresh this
old one and now this one actually
doesn't show up anymore and that's
because every time that we basically
invoke this function we're removing this
old blob URL so that's what's helpful
where when you fetch this new item we're
adding this in and that's why we can
refresh this one because this is the
active one but as soon as we were to
replace this body and then add a new one
this one won't exist
so the image might get generated but
it'll be a different ID and then it
won't work and we can actually test this
where let's say that we
refresh this
then we try to refresh now we actually
don't see that anymore
but this is going to be in a different
one so you'll see that there is a
difference between those IDs and that's
why this one when we refresh this is the
active one and we're able to see that
but the old version we don't have that
anymore
so this is great so now we know that our
Lambda function is able to generate this
string
the base64 encoded string we're able to
decode that in the front end and now
really all that's left here is that we
want to tie up this Lambda call so that
we're able to then get that response
dynamically passed into our application
we're going to switch out the quote and
we don't need to keep setting it
manually every time we can just
programmatically have that working in
the background and then display that for
our users in the front end so let's do
that right now
so now that we have this function
working to be able to take this string
and then turn it into something that our
users can see let's actually go back
into our application and see what we got
so if we refresh the page I'm sure
you'll see that
we get this quotes generated number and
it's not zero anymore now it's changing
so if we try to do this one more time we
try to test it
we'll be able to get a new value right
and now if we go back to the front end
if we refresh that number should before
so let's see if it did that
because we tested it and we did the same
test
we might need to run the test again so
if we do test again
try refreshing
and now we do that so just if you are
running through this just make sure that
you refresh your Lambda
you run through the test
if you do that again
now we refresh here
now you get five so you'll have to
refresh the Lambda every time to run the
test but then you'll be able to get that
working so that's awesome so now we have
our Lambda script that is updating this
dynamodb table every time that it runs
so this is that event driven
architecture where we don't have to
manually update the database it's
already doing that every time that the
script or the function is invoked and
executes correctly so that's great so
now that we have this now what we're
going to do is we're going to take our
our
image blob and we're going to pass down
so instead of The Blob URL being set
inside of this component we're actually
going to be setting this outside of it
through a fetch function so what we do
is that we're going to be creating a
function to get
that quote string and then we're going
to be able to bring that into the front
end so and then use typescript to decode
that string but we need a function that
we can call publicly to think at that
data point
if you remember from the beginning when
we set up our handle open generator
function we had a try catch and we set
that set timeout function and then we
said that we're going to add some Lambda
function code later but we weren't going
to do it right now well
the moment has arrived so what we're
going to do is that we're going to be
updating this function
to then call our Lambda function and the
way that we're going to do this is
actually in a pretty crafty way using
our API so we can
just unpack this really quick
so
when we have our query
here
so we have this generate a quote query
we're going to pass in some AWS Json
and then as that input string
we allow Public Access via IM to then
run this function which is inspo quote
Lambda so what we're going to do is that
we're going to run
this query
this custom query to then run this
Lambda function so
in this code what we're going to do is
that we're going to
have a variable called const run
function
equals run function so it's going to be
a string we're then going to stringify
that value so we're going to do run
function stringify equals Json springify
and then we're going to add that value
in here
then we're going to do is that we're
going to take a response
of response equals a weight
and then we're going to do API Dot
graphql
and then
we're going to have a generate
a quote
test data quote
data
and then that's where we're going to
start
creating
some autocomplete stuffs happening there
we're going to start working on
our query so we're going to do is that
we're going to say for query
we're going to say generate a quote
and we can rewrite the last letter and
then it's going to import generate a
quote from our queries
we'll then say auth mode
is AWS IM
then for the variables
as our input we're going to put our run
function stringified
as that value
and then we will do that we'll log that
out
and then what we're going to do is that
we're going to try to stringify
that response so we're going to do const
response
stringified
equals Json stringify
we're then going to restringify that
response
which is this value there
then what we're going to do is we are
going to
do kant's body index equals response
restring
ified
index of
body equals this
plus five
on the next line
we're going to have our const
body and base 64.
equals response stringified
substring body index
so overall what we're going to be doing
is that we're going to get a response
but it's going to be a lot of Json data
what we're going to want to do is
stringify it and then we're going to
basically find where body equals this
and then extract the string and then
that's where we're going to have that
element that we have in quotes we want
to extract that from the response that
we get so that's why we're doing all of
this string manipulation to get to that
value
so
then we need to get the body array
equals body and base 64 and we're going
to split it
right there at that comma
then we're going to do is we're going to
do const body equals body array
we'll get the first value of that
and then we'll do console log body
then we're going to set quote received
as that body value
then we're going to
take out our set timeout because we
don't need that anymore
but I'm going to end state
which is set
processing quote
to be false
and this is because in the beginning
we set processing quote to be true so
now since we've gotten the response we
want to set it to be false
and then we also want to fetch with any
new
quotes
for our generated
from counter
so then we'll do update quote info
just as a function to catch for that
so now this seems like a function that
we'll want to do but of course with
typescript we're going to need to create
these props
so what we're going to need to do is as
I'm sure you've guessed it we're going
to need to generate an interface
so we're going to do is that we're going
to
create an interface and I'm going to put
this
above
we're actually yeah we'll put that above
so we'll say interface
for
our
appsync
2 Lambda
Json response
so interface
generate a quotient data
then we'll do this that we're going to
do generate
a quote
and that's coming from this value
will then get a status code
which is a number
we'll then get headers
and in this array we're going to get a
key which will be a string
and then that
itself is a string
and then the body is also going to be a
string
so that should log out exactly what we
need so now we're going to do is that
we're going to give this a save and then
every time that this function runs we're
going to hope that we are
so in that function that we we just
created right so in this try catch we
get a response we want to be logging
this body so the body is hopefully going
to be that really long string that we
usually put in quotes manually we want
to be able to set that here so we want
to see if we can log this and if we can
log this we'll be able to pass this down
as props into our child's component and
then render that image dynamically so
let us see if we're able to do that so
I'm going to open up
the console
and I'm going to give this a refresh
and then we're going to make a quote
and then every time that this
runs
looks like we got it okay
so we still need to work on the styles
with the state but
if you see this this looks exactly like
r
basic 64 encoded string that we would
usually get so this looks awesome so
what we're going to do is that we're
going to
just remember these characters and also
just give a check just a gut check just
to make sure that this actually is in
fact giving us different values here
so what we do is that and we also see
that this is going to be increasing
which is going to be great
so now what we want to do is that
we just want to check to see if this is
going to be the same value or if it's
going to be different so
that's IB
you are
w
oh
yeah so it's a little bit hard to tell
but it looks like right now we are going
to be able to get the different values
for our images but we'll still want to
check to make sure that that actually is
the case so just go the scroll back here
so what we're going to now do is we're
going to scroll down
and in here under quote modal we see
that we're going to be set processing
quote as set processing quote quote is
received there so we're passing down
these properties into our component now
we're going to want to do is
we want to make sure that the quote
received is actually a part of that now
when we go to the image blob URL
what we're going to want to do is we're
going to want to of course remove this
because we're going to be getting the
blob URL
outside of that
so now we're going to do is that we're
going to
hide a lot of this code here just to
make this easier
we're gonna
comment out all of this code
like all of this code
because we're already doing this outside
of the function and we're not going to
need it
in there and then we'll comment this out
because we're going to be passing that
blob URL down through our image blob
now something that we're going to need
to do is it's going to say that there is
a type error with quote received
so we're going to try to find out what's
up with that
so
now if we make this
string or we make this null
we can see if that will
get rid of the error
which it did so that's good now what
we're going to want to do is
in our check so we had that image blob
URL which will give this a save
there is
this and we want to make sure that so
remember when we were doing this testing
so if Court received is not null
meaning there is a value that's filled
with it then we want to show it here
so what we're going to now do is we're
going to go back to our application
we'll give this a refresh and we're
going to see if we can
call
this
so it's generating a quote
and look at that so now it's working
and then if we click out of this if we
try to make another quote
so now it's going to be making a new one
so now something that I do want to do
though is that let's make it a little
bit cleaner of every time that we fetch
because we still want to make it look a
little bit smoother and I think that we
can do that
so what we're going to do is that we're
going to go back to our function and
what we're going to do is that we want
to
update some of these states to then
refresh and clear out the quote so every
time that you you clear out of or you
click out of the modal will then be
changing it so that it'll show creating
your quote every time that a new quote
is being generated as opposed to just
switching in the image it's great that
we have the image but we want to make
the front end look a little bit more
like it's generating the code than just
the quote appearing you know kind of out
of thin air so that's what we'll be
doing next to fix that close function so
that it looks a little bit more
programmatic we're going to need to go
back to our parent component and then
open up the handle closed generator
function and we're going to need to add
a little bit more data to this so before
we originally just
setting the open generator modal as
false so that it would close it but now
what we want to do is we want to when we
close the modal at any time we also want
to set the processing quote to be false
and then we also want to set
quote received to be null so this is how
we're going to set it where that type
where we configured it before where it's
either a string or it's no well anytime
that we close it we want to set
basically this modal to be false the
processing quote you know the loading
state to be false and then we also want
to set the quote received to be null so
that means that there's nothing in the
quote received there's nothing for the
blob URL to be showing we want to make
it where there's nothing there
so the way that this will work is that
will refresh
now when we make a quote
we're going to get that loading state
get that loading State and then we'll
get that image
and then that works like an image and
that's great and let's actually open
this up in a new tab
these other ones we can close out of
and then when we close this out we'll
make a new quote and now it's going to
reload it again and now we have a
different image and let's open that up
here
so we have these two images but if we
refresh this one that was the one that
we we first called
and this is the one that we just got so
we're gonna refresh here and then still
same deal let's make a new quote
and then we have a new one so let's open
up this one here
and let's open up a new one
and look at that so we have all these
different images here
and it's looking pretty good so far and
of course we get the data this is all
mapping against and uh against these
updates to the function and if we make
another quote
we'll get that 12. so the data is also
incrementing
we also are getting all of the quotes
generated and this is all happening
without any sort of storage any sort of
you know images being stored in cloud
storage these are all just strings that
then we decode in the front end so that
you never have to worry about
scalability concerns it's that it's
sending the exact data that you want
from your Lambda function to your user
in the front end so this is a really
cool way where you see how the backend
code can connect to the front end and
you can have a pretty cool working
application and I'm sure you're
wondering with that awesome download
your quote button does that actually
work and does that actually let us
download our quote that we just received
and it actually does so if we press this
button we'll be able to save this to
a folder and now if we open it
we'll actually be able to see that
and what's really cool is that this is a
real image so we have text in there and
that's where we're actually able to
click on links and this is a real
working image and let's say that we
wanted to
do another one
so we generate one right there and now
if we download this quote
it'll already start you know making it
where we'll say quote number one we'll
open this up
and check that out and now we have
another one so again really easy really
cool way to just add more functionality
to your images that you generated and
allow your users to also you know you
could copy or save this image yourself
you could also open it up in a new tab
or you can also allow users to download
that file so they can save that right to
their computer and it's with that blog
URL that was generated from that base60
for encoded string so as we review our
application everything seems to be in
order based upon what we're expecting
and all the features that we're hoping
to have as a part of our application
so we'll refresh this again
we'll make another quote and seems like
everything is working as per we would
expect which is great and we have the
download button we have this
we can you know make a quote generate a
quote our dynamodb
you know quote generated number is
operating effectively so now we're going
to do is we're going to take our
localhost application and then we're
going to put this right on the cloud
with AWS using AWS managed hosting so
one thing before we do that that'll be
really important of course for us is to
make sure that all of our code is saved
so you don't have any anything left over
in terms of code being need to be saved
so we are going to
of course just
make sure that our amplify
doesn't have anything that's impending
for us to push to the cloud
so there's no change there's no change
there's no change which is perfect so
that means that we are all set to commit
this code locally so we're going to say
finished build
and we'll say finish local build so we
will Commit This to Maine we're going to
push this to GitHub
and now
now the fun stuff now the fun part
begins so now when we have this main
branch so what we're going to do is that
we're going to and I'm going to draw
this out just so that it is a little bit
easier to see
so when we have our GitHub so this is
going to be GitHub and we have code here
so this is related to our project so we
have Main
and that's the current build that we
have so we have code
code goes into GitHub and then that's
stored and then we have all of this you
know state right so we're tracking all
these things but what we want to be able
to do is that we want to be able to have
a methodology where you push code
it's given this prod
characteristic that's going to go to
GitHub
and then GitHub is then going to run a
build in AWS so AWS
this is our cloud
so that we're able to then have our code
go on the production Branch go to GitHub
GitHub isn't going to speak to AWS and
then we have our www
website that users can see when they log
on
and that's where AWS is going to be
creating this website for US based upon
the code that we come in because right
now we're just managing you know git
history and that's great but we really
want to be able to do is commit to a
specific branch have GitHub tell AWS to
commit that code to a build and then
we're going to be able to use that and
we're going to use AWS amplify with
managed hosting to be able to accomplish
that goal so let's see how to add
amplify hosting to our application to
add hosting to our
AWS project we're going to say amplify
add hosting
to
our CLI
now we see two specific options one is
hosting with amplify console and that's
managed hosting with custom domains
continuous deployment and then the other
option is Amazon cloudfront and S3 so
we're going to choose amplify console
for manage hosting because they also
have support for server-side rendering
and that's going to be really important
for our application to be able to work
dynamically and leverage all of the
features of nexjs and typescript so then
when we configure a type there are
basically two different types there's
continuous deployment which is git based
through GitHub and manual deployment so
we're going to choose continuous
deployment
now what we're going to do is that we're
going to need to configure our
AWS project so what we're going to do is
that we're going to go back to amplify
we're going to go to hosting
and this is our application this is our
app we're going to go to GitHub and
we're going to press that
we're going to press connect
now we see that GitHub authorization was
successful and unless you've connected
this GitHub repository to your amplify
project before
in this drop down you won't see your
repository so what we're going to do is
we're going to go to view GitHub
permissions
and we're going to go to
and now what we're going to do is that
we're going to scroll and we're going to
select the repositories that we want to
be able to access so for this
we're going to find the inspirational
quote generator
which is our first
quarter repository there we're going to
press save
we'll see that
AWS amplify Us East one was updated for
my account
now we will go back to
so we'll go back to our AWS amplify
project
we'll press GitHub
to reauthorize
now in our list of drop downs we should
see this right at the top
and
for main that's our current Branch but
something that we're going to do is
we're going to be a little bit fancier
so what we're going to do is that we are
going to
in our GitHub desktop application we're
going to create a new Branch we're going
to call it prod
and this is going to be our prod branch
that we are going to configure so any
pushes
any commits that are made specifically
to the production Branch we're then
going to run a build on that
so we're going to publish this branch
and it's based off of Main
and then we'll bring this away refresh
the the actual page so
we might need to run this one more time
so we could use your previous press
continue
find our code repository there
and now under Branch we should see prod
there
so now when we see prod we're going to
click next
and when we click to this next screen
we're going to see the app name which is
our amplify app name it's already Auto
detecting that we're using next.js with
server-side rendering which is what
we're doing and we also are going to be
using the amplify framework for our back
end and what's really great about
amplify hosting is that it's already
pre-configured for the server-side
rendering that is uh basically I think
one of the strongest features of the
next JS with typescript framework for
building apps so this is already
pre-loaded with that which is awesome so
now as we scroll down we're going to
select backend environment to work with
this so inspirational quotes which is
this app we're going to enable full
stack continuous deployments with CI CD
so that means that when we push to prod
we're going to then be running a build
and we're going to be using this Dev
environment now something that you could
do is that if you wanted to create new
environments based upon your Cloud
backend you could have a production
Cloud Branch similar to as we have a
prod Cloud branch that we're just using
Dev just because we're just building
this app but if you wanted to make this
more robust you could have different
types of cloud environments and then
switch between those in your builds in
your testing in your local you know
development pipeline so just really good
ways to Leverage The amplify framework
for your whole team's development but
we're just going to be using the dev
Branch because that's what we configured
and then we're going to select an
existing role or create a new one so you
could create a new role if you don't
already have one configured but I
already have an amplify console backend
rule configured so I'm going to use this
one
and then what we can do is that we can
also just check out what the build and
test settings are so when we have our
back end we are going to have some
phases and in our builds we're going to
use the amplify push simple script and
that's just executing amplify CLI and
then what we're going to do is that
we're going to run through a pre-build
which is I'm going to do npmci for
getting node modules and then we're
going to use this build commands to run
our the build of our application because
we're using xjs this is going to have as
our export dot next folder and then
we're going to be looking through the
files of that to build our project and
then of course with caching related to
node modules this is an important step
to make sure that you know your caching
known modules and not you know keep
installing them or keep adding to them
over time but you could actually cache
them and use them in subsequent builds
if nothing is changing with your
packages
so you could also configure advanced
settings as well and this can become
really important when you're working
with containers and with Docker so you
could actually reference your own build
images or use amplifies default build
container so more you could learn more
about this if that's something that's
important to you in terms of containers
and um you know really just building you
know some sort of kubernetes deployment
uh infrastructure um you can also add
environmental variables in case there's
certain branches that you want to work
from there's certain environmental
variables related to maybe API calls
that you're working from or certain
tools or infrastructure so just
important to know that you can do that
from this screen as well and then also
we are you going to be using the amplify
cli's the latest version this is
actually really important because if you
ever are running a build and you get an
error related to maybe the CLI what you
can do is that if you have previous
builds that have worked you could revert
back to the previous amplify CLI version
this was actually an error that I had
experienced and needed to revert back
temporarily to a previous amplify CLI
version and that was able to help me get
over that barrier to use the right CLI
to deploy my application
so if this all looks good we'll click
next
and it's just going to have us Recon
reconfirm all of the settings that we've
selected so again we're using GitHub
this is the application that we have
worked on together we're going to use
the prod branch in GitHub we're using
the dev Branch that's the cloud branch
and we're going to be using the default
image
this is our Dev Branch environmental
variable of course we're using next.js
with server-side rendering and amplify
and it's Auto detecting these settings
that will be used so as soon as we click
save and deploy it's going to run
through this build process to show how
we can build our application to the
cloud we will press save and deploy
and now what it's going to do is that
it's going to start running through
these stages of our build pipeline and
it gives us a nice graphical user
interface
chart of where we are in the process so
what you can see here you can get
actually a lot of really interesting
details related to each stage and
we'll be able to see how it's
provisioning the docker image it's on a
host with four V CPU and seven gigabytes
memory and then it says that each build
image gets its own host instance
ensuring that all resources are isolated
and the contents of the docker file are
displayed below for your information so
in case you want to see more of actually
how this is provisioning
our application
you'll be able to see all of this
which I think is actually really helpful
to see how they're building the
application in the background because it
can become a little bit nebulous as to
what's really going on
now
it's going to start cloning the
repository from GitHub and this is a
private repository so it is a secure
connection to be able to get access to
this build and then there's going to be
a series of different steps that it will
take from build to test to deploy and
then that's how we'll be able to get
this working now when you use amplify
it's going to configure
a branch name dot a number of characters
dot amplifyapp.com so if we click on
this and we open it in a new tab
we're going to see something that looks
like this so it's going to say that your
app will appear here once you complete
your first deployment
so this is just going to be a
placeholder
you know
index.html file until we're able to
build this out and we're already getting
some errors from here so we're going to
need to figure out what's going on here
and it seems like
what ended up happening was so we can go
through this
set package Lambda failed with error
command Fields exit and Pim install
production omit Dev instead
so there's going to be something related
to inspirational quote Lambda known
module is sharp that it did not like so
this is where we're going to need to
then go back and
re-run our application because it seemed
like it didn't like the specific package
that
we needed for our Lambda script so this
is where we're going to need to figure
out basically how to navigate this
so we'll do that in the next step but if
you also want to download the build logs
you can also do that too and that can be
helpful but sometimes also if you ever
get any errors you'll need to then go
back to the drawing board and see
basically what went wrong and then
figure out a solve so that you can get
it to work so if you remember that we
installed the sharp package in a very
specific way when we were back in our
code base here
what we're going to need to do is that
we're going to need to basically do that
same thing so when we installed sharp
with this specific version we also added
a Linux version and we also added a uh
x64 architecture uh flag so those were
that was the arch flag and then the
platform flag for Linux so we're going
to need to make sure that we do that in
our package.json and then in our build
script we're going to need to make sure
that we edit that as well so I'm back in
the function so this again is under back
end under function and then
under package.json we're going to need
to install uh have an installation
script
that we can then add into our
application so under Main
something you can do is you can say
Scripts
we'll give that an object
press enter
and then under here we're going to say
install
Sharp
then we're going to say npm
and PM install
we're going to do dash dash Arch equals
X 64. and then we're going to do dash
dash platform
equals Linux
and we'll say sharp and then this is
going to be a script that we will
incorporate as part of our build script
so then we're going to go back to the
amplify
dashboard we're going to go to our build
settings
and we're going to edit this
and then
you'll see here when we are trying to
execute amplify CLI with the helper
script so what we're going to do is that
we're going to install a specific
script for that function that we just
ran
so when we do
npm run install dash dash Sharp
with the prefix then under amplify
backend function in spokote Lambda
SRC
that's where we're going to then be
running
this installation for that specific
sharp package that's in our source then
we'll do the amplify push simple command
and then we'll be able to run our build
related to that so we're going to press
save
now what we're going to do is we're
going to go back to our function
and then we're going to do
amplify status
and
we see that there is a function that's
updating and there's the hosting that's
updating so we're going to do is we're
going to say amplify
push
and then that's going to push our
install Sharp
script there to the cloud
so we're going to be configuring that
and then
R amplify push command will be running
to update our cloud formation stack
and I will pause this recording and then
resume it when all the resources are
pushed to the cloud and then we can run
a build again
so now that our code was pushed to the
cloud
something that we can do is
commit directly to production
and something also that we can do is we
can switch to the main branch
and we can say bring my changes to Main
we can say we'll switch branch
and now we're going to do is we're going
to say updated
Lambda
install script
for built
we'll Commit This to Main
we'll push this
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to go back to our GitHub
repository
we're going to go to pull requests
and actually we could just go back to
code and
just validate that the code was just
pushed so we'll do refresh
and we just committed code literally
just a moment ago so we'll go back to
pull requests we're going to do new pull
request we're going to do
Main and then we're going to push to
production
so that's the before this is the after
so we're able to merge that we're going
to create and this is the script the um
the GitHub commit that we just made so
we'll do commit to this
we're going to create pull request
and then we'll merge the request and
we'll confirm merge
and now if we go back to our amplify
project
we should be able to see that we now
have a build running so this is a really
cool aspect of CI CD is that as soon as
we committed to the production Branch we
now are able to have a build running to
then build to this URL so now it's going
to go through those same processes this
is build number two
and now we're able to see that we're
able to go through the provision stage
and
access all of these same steps that we
had before except we don't have to
really tell
the application to or the configuration
to do anything it's already going to
start building our application
because we set up the CI CD rules for it
so now when we go to
this build it's going to be cloning our
repository once more
and
we're going to wait until it can start
configuring
our application
so
we'll just have to wait until
this build continues and then we'll be
able to keep watching for it
but it seems like it's done with the
amplify CLI
and now it's going to go to the back end
so now we're going to see if that back
end patch fixed our build
error
so the schema was compiled successfully
we're now going to be updating
and uploading those files
and we're going to be waiting for
a success marker about if the Lambda was
updated
so so far so good
seems like
there's the update that's in progress
and it's going to be checking to see
basically those changes that we worked
on so
we have our update in progress
and this is just going to be configuring
our stack
there's also some elements of appsync
that look like they're in there
so we'll just wait for this to configure
and go through the build process
so now it's going to be continuing to go
through and uploading the files
and looks like our API worked great and
it initialized the environment
successfully and we were able to
complete the builds process so that was
awesome that we were able to configure
this correctly and that push was able to
solve that build error that we got so
now it's going to start in this next
phase which is the front end build it's
going to be taking our code that we just
pushed
and this is really important because
when we are pushing back-end code and
front-end code we want to make sure that
the back end and the amplify framework
is compiling everything successfully so
that we can then
build everything together because the
front end is dependent upon the back end
working so now that our back end was
able to be built correctly through that
patch that we put through now we're able
to then make sure that our front end
works
which it will so now it's going to be
generating the static pages
and then it'll also be adding in the
server side renders for server-side
rendering as well
so now it's creating the cache artifact
and uploading the cache artifacts
and the caching was complete the
environment caching completed as well
and now it's going to terminate logs
and then we should be able to have a
living breathing URL
momentarily
so this is exciting so this is where our
application is finally going to be able
to be pushed to a actual URL and we'll
be able to take this off of localhost
and push this onto a domain that people
could use and you'll be able to send
this URL to you know your friends family
your colleagues anyone that you want
maybe a potential employer and this is
an application that you could share and
show that you built it
this I think is pretty exciting
so now that we have our deploy script
set up
we can go back to this URL and we can
see if it built
so we'll give this a refresh
and we'll wait for our app to load
all right
so this is pretty exciting this is the
application that we built and the Styles
seem to be working there
we can also check to see if it works so
let's make a quote
it's going to be generating a quote and
look at that so this is our actual
script and we're able to run it now on
an actual domain in an actual URL so we
can also you know download that quote
card if we wanted to and this will work
the same way
and if we wanted to do that we could see
that here and then this is that quote
that we got so everything seems to be
working
completely and this is going to be
updating as well we'll make another
quote
and this is another one
18. we'll add another one
19th quote that was generated
and these are all real images that we
are fetching and of course this is still
using our local storage with our blob
URL so we can test that again so let's
say that we want to make another quote
so now we'll open this up in another tab
that was one we just did we'll refresh
this and this of course doesn't exist
but this one still does
and then if we make another quote
we'll open this one up
that one won't exist but then this one
will
so this is pretty awesome so
this is now working and we have a fully
functional application that is running
so if you want to you know build
Graphics in the cloud you can totally do
that and this is an application that
shows that this is all possible
all right congratulations you just built
an inspirational quote generator and we
did quite a lot of stuff so we
configured a nexjs with typescript and
style components application we created
our own API we created our own
serverless infrastructure to generate an
image and we also created a processing
system where we're able to create
continuous integration and continuous
deployment from our code to our cloud
and deploy that live with a real URL and
created a whole application to support
that whole workflow so I hope that this
project was really insightful and
helpful for you and I would love to see
uh you post about what you're building
on social whether it's this project or
another project I'll include my handle
it's Brian H huff and I would love to
just you know hear what you're building
and I'd be happy to support you in your
journey building full stack applications
microservices and anything on the
internet internet so with that I hope
you have a great rest of your day
afternoon or evening depending on
wherever you are in the world and I hope
that you continue to build really cool
technology all right take care everyone
bye